Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Ich bin kein Hacker, das ist klar. Nein. Ich wollte FIFA und UEFA helfen, diese Schnauze zu schliessen. Wenn ich die Fußballinstitutionen sehe, sehe ich viele Veränderungen. Das ist ein Geschäft, in dem alle sich sich verteidigen.
Jahrelang war er ein Phantom. Jetzt hören wir ihn selbst sprechen. Das war Rui Pedro Goncalves Pinto, der Mann, der hinter Football Leaks steckt und lange nur als John bekannt war. Seine Identität wurde enttarnt. Er wurde von Ungarn nach Portugal ausgeliefert und wartet dort auf seinen Prozess. Nicht nur deshalb gibt es viel zu den Football Leaks zu besprechen. Und umso mehr freue ich mich, dass ich den Journalisten hier begrüßen kann, der lange Zeit als einziger persönlicher Kontakt zu Pinto hatte. Rafael Buschmann vom Spiegel, Ed Raffanelli auf Twitter. Hi Rafael.
Ich freue mich über die Einladung. Vielen Dank, Hi Max.
Ja, schön, dass du wieder da bist. Es wird zu einer liebgewonnenen Tradition, dass wir hier über die Football Leaks sprechen. Bevor wir loslegen, danke ich Simon W. Hannes aus Berlin, Richard, der Weinstube Sachsenhausen. Ich hoffe, das war jetzt keine Werbung in diesem werbefreien Podcast. Claudio, Erik Pietzschmann, der sagt, der Club steigt nicht ab, ist noch eine alte Supporter-Registrierungs-Sorri dafür. FCN 13 und Maike Essenbreis, sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Der Rasenfunk ist wie immer werbesponsoren und paywallfrei, erlebt allein von eurer finanziellen Unterstützung. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Ja Rafael, wir haben jetzt schon häufig über Football Leaks gesprochen. Insgesamt gibt es einen Kurzpass dazu und drei Tribünengespräche, die wir alle samt in dieser Konstellation gemacht haben. Bei einem war noch Nicole selber mit zu Gast. Unglaublich, was sich alles getan hat. Jetzt ist ein neues Buch erschienen, Football Leaks – Zwei neue Enthüllungen aus der Welt des Profifußballs von dir und Michael Wulzinger erschienen im DVA Verlag. Und nachdem wir jetzt das letzte Mal vor einem Jahr miteinander gesprochen haben, ziemlich genau, erstmal die ganz banale Frage, was war denn jetzt so los im letzten Jahr bei dir?
Puh, kurze Frage, Bedarf einer langen Antwort. Das Jahr war im beruflichen, journalistischen Sinne wahrscheinlich das schwierigste, auch das anstrengendste Jahr das ich bislang hatte. Schlicht und ergreifend, weil in dieses Jahr auch noch die letzte Phase der Football Leaks Veröffentlichung reinfiel, die wir im vergangenen November nach fast sieben Monaten Arbeit daran veröffentlicht haben. Aber danach eben im Januar die Verhaftung von Rui Pinto, die wirklich uns ziemlich wie einen Schock getroffen hat. Es klingt so bescheuert, aber man bereitet sich darauf im Geist immer so ein bisschen vor, weil man weiß, es gibt Behörden, die ihn verfolgen, es gibt Behörden, die ihn vor Gericht stellen wollen und natürlich werden sie irgendwann mal ihn auch bekommen. Aber wenn es dann passiert, zieht es einem doch schon ganz schön die Schuhe aus. Und dann haben wir noch relativ lange hin und her überlegt, ob wir trotz der Verhaftung das zweite Buch in der Phase noch schreiben können, schreiben sollen. Wir haben uns aber genau aus den Gründen dafür entschlossen, weil wir gesagt haben, dass die Geschichte von Rui Pinto erzählt werden muss, dass wir auch diese Verantwortung dafür tragen, wenn wir solange mit ihm in so engem Kontakt standen, dass wir seine Geschichte eben auch nochmal in die Öffentlichkeit bringen und für uns auch eine Form von, ja, so eine Art Dach über dieses Projekt nochmal setzen. Dieses Buch ist ja, es sind ja nicht nur neue Enthüllungen, sondern dieses Buch ist ja im Prinzip eine Projektbeschreibung der zweiten Projektphase, inklusive der Arbeit mit dem Whistleblower. Also insofern, in dem vergangenen Jahr war gut zu tun.
Ja, es ist auch ein deutlich längeres Buch geworden als das erste. 555 Seiten ohne Epilog und das Glossar noch dahinter. Also rund doppelt so dick wie das erste Buch. Was ist denn jetzt neu an Football Leaks 2 für diejenigen, die vielleicht auch Football Leaks 1 schon gelesen haben?
Also wir bleiben ja auch bei dem zweiten Buch in dem Strang, den wir beim ersten Buch gewählt haben. Das heißt, dass wir zwischen Enthüllungsgeschichten oder Datengeschichten oder Recherchgeschichten einen Bruch machen und immer die Geschichte von John erzählen bzw. seine Auseinandersetzung mit dem Fußballbusiness, mit Behörden, mit dem Druck auf ihn und natürlich auch mit dem Wunsch als Whistleblower auszusteigen. Zu den neuen Enthüllungen ist zu sagen, dass wir einen Mix gewählt haben zwischen den Geschichten, die wir in den letzten zwei Jahren veröffentlicht haben. Die haben wir zum Teil weiter recherchiert oder haben rund um diese Geschichten nochmal Blöcke gesetzt, die den Rechercheansatz erklären oder unsere Recherchereisen nochmal einordnen. Und es gibt vollkommen neue Geschichten, die wir aus dem Datenmaterial in den vergangenen Monaten herausgeholt haben, wie beispielsweise eine vollkommen irre dreistellige Millionenzahlung der UEFA an eine BVI-Firma, obwohl das Geld eigentlich dem ukrainischen Verband zugutekommen sollte. Es gibt einen Enthüllungskapitel zum Geld, das Papa Messi erhalten hat über eine ähnliche Konstruktion, wie die damals in Verruf geratene Konstruktion, die den beiden Messis, die das Gerichtsverfahren bzw. die Verurteilung eingebrockt hat vor ein paar Jahren, über diese Geldschleuse sind noch einmal Zahlungen gelaufen, von denen wir nicht wissen, ob tatsächlich die Behörden davon Kenntnis hatten. Wir haben Enthüllungen zum Jugendspielerbereich, wir haben Enthüllungen zum Umgehungstatbeständen des Financial Fairplays. Wir haben uns diesmal sehr intensiv mit dem TV-Markt beschäftigt und festgestellt, wie dort jede Sauerei irgendwann mal angerissen wurde, weil es einfach so viele davon gab, und haben aber dann in den Daten festgestellt, dass das keineswegs so ist und dass wir insbesondere eine Firma gefunden haben, die uns sehr beschäftigt hat, weil sie einfach zu unterschiedlichen Stellen auswüchse hatte. Da sind personelle Verquickungen zwischen den TV-Rechteinhabern, die aus unserer Sicht ziemlich schamlos schmieren. Also Gelder laufen lassen, die eigentlich so nicht laufen sollten, und die gleichzeitig personelle Verquickungen haben zum Spielerberaterbereich, und zwar zu einer hochrangigen Spielerberaterfirma, zu der wir dann im Buch auch noch ein bisschen was zu erzählen haben.
Das war jetzt ein ganz kurzer Abriss. Ich würde da gerne gleich noch, zumindest an ein paar Stellen, auch noch mit der Lupe kurz mit draufstehen wollen, aber noch kurz zur Form des Buches. Das war auch schon beim ersten Football Leaks Buch so, dass viel im Wir geschrieben wird. In diesem Buch wechselt es jetzt mehr zwischen Wir und Ich und das Ich ist in der Form dann deine Person. Du spielst generell eine größere Person im Buch als jetzt in der ersten Ausgabe. Warum?
Schwierig zu sagen. Weiß ich nicht, ob das so ist. Möglicherweise ist es aufgrund der Seitenzahl so. Aber die Rolle hat sich natürlich insofern verändert, weil ich deutlich mehr Kontakt eben auch über den langen Zeitraum mit Rui Pinto hatte. Ein großer Anteil des Buches ist nun mal Rui Pintos Weg vom Whistleblower bis zur Auslieferung. Das ist ein Weg, den ich leider nicht mehr Rui Pinto erzählen lassen konnte, weil alle unsere Versuche, nochmal mit Rui Pinto in Kontakt zu kommen, nach seiner Auslieferung sind an der portugiesischen Justiz gescheitert, da die portugiesische Justiz ihm generell ein Verbot erteilt hat, mit Medien zu sprechen. Was ein bisschen absurd ist, weil er ja nach seiner Verhaftung noch zwei Monate im Hausarrest verbracht hat und dort auch ganz normal Interviews gegeben hat und mit Medien gesprochen hat. Und warum zwischen der Hausarrestzeit und der U-Haftzeit eine inhaltliche Veränderung stattgefunden haben soll, erschließt sich, glaube ich, niemanden.
Gilt es denn generell für Medien oder haben sie nur euch den Kontakt untersagt? Es könnte ja auch sein, dass ihr Bestandteil der Untersuchungen seid.
Soweit wir wissen, gilt es generell für alle Medien. Wir haben auch keine Kenntnis darüber, dass wir in irgendeiner Form Bestandteile in das Ermittlungsgefahren sind.
Würdest du denn sagen, die Football Leaks sind ein Sachbuch oder ein Roman?
Das ist ein Sachbuch. Selbstverständlich ist es ein Sachbuch. Natürlich gibt es dort Elemente, die erzählerisch sind, weil es gar nicht anders geht, wenn man eine Reportage schreibt. Das sind nun mal Reportageelemente, die man mit jemanden zusammen erlebt. Aber generell ist es ein Sachbuch, weil wir natürlich auch den Anspruch haben, so nah wie möglich auch an den Daten zu bleiben und an dem zu bleiben, wie wir es erlebt haben. Allerdings gibt es in der Tat einen Punkt, der nicht ganz so einfach ist, den beschreiben wir auch vorne im Prolog. Wenn man so viel mit einer Quelle erlebt, würde man die Quelle natürlich auch vorher gerne darum bitten, all dies einmal zu prüfen und dazu ein Feedback zu geben. Ich habe über viele Elemente des Buches vorher auch schon mit John gesprochen und ihm gesagt, in welche Richtung ich das Ganze schreiben möchte oder bzw. welche Elemente ich aufnehmen möchte. Aber eben aufgrund der Verhaftung nicht bis zum Schluss.
Ja, also es gibt interessante Passagen, auch fast komische Passagen, die eben dann ja sehr prosaisch daherkommen. Das hast du ja selber auch schon im ersten Buch ja auch schon, war das so ein bisschen der Stil. Dadurch liest es sich, glaube ich, schneller. Aber ich war ein bisschen, ich hatte das Gefühl, dass diese Passagen länger waren im zweiten Buch. Das hängt natürlich auch mit der Geschichte zusammen, dass eben John alias Rui Pinto noch mehr in den Fokus gerückt ist. Aber es hat noch mehr zugenommen. Also ich glaube, jetzt euer Spiegelteam besser zu kennen, weil du es ausführlich beschrieben hast, mit Ausnahme von wenigen Personen, die dann nicht beschrieben werden. Und das hat so ein bisschen den Fokus verschoben, hatte ich den Eindruck. Einfach im Vergleich, ich habe beide Bücher noch mal gelesen, da war das zweite jetzt eben wesentlich mehr in diesem Reportagesstil angelegt. War aber keine bewusste Entscheidung.
Nein, bewusst war die Entscheidung zu sagen, dass wir das Team, das Football Leaks Team, deutlich stärker in den Vordergrund rücken möchten, um auch zu erklären, wie wir beispielsweise getrennt haben zwischen Informant und Information. Also, dass wir am Ende uns nicht darauf verlassen haben, was ein Informant uns erzählt, sondern eben auch ein Team dahinter hatten, das sehr intensiv mit den Dokumenten, mit den Rechercheansätzen gearbeitet hat, das ins Feld rausgegangen ist und mit weiteren Leuten geredet hat, das gereist ist um die einzelnen Ansätze, die wir auch aus den Daten oder die wir von Rui Pinto erhalten haben, um sie weiter auszuformulieren, um sie weiter zu prüfen. Ich fand es wichtig, dass wir diese zweite Ebene, dieses zweite Element in dem Buch mit etablieren, um auch den Lesern einfach eine gewisse Transparenz über die Art der Arbeit zu geben, die wir hier führen.
Aber wir haben in den vergangenen Sendungen schon häufig, also wer sich für den Themenkomplex interessiert, der sollte unbedingt auch noch die anderen drei Tribüngespräche hören, wir haben auch schon häufiger darüber gesprochen, dass ja ein Teil der Kritik, der von Seiten anderer Medien an den Football Leaks ausgeübt wird, viel mit der Form der Darstellung zu tun hat. Glaubst du, das macht jetzt auch dieses zweite Buch, anfälliger für Kritik, wenn da eben Personenbeschreibungen drin sind, also eine Anwältsgehilfin riecht nach Sommer, zum Beispiel, das ist jetzt ein wörtliches Zitat. Das ist ja eigentlich eine nicht nötige Information.
Aber ist es nicht, also ich versuche diese Frage jetzt ein bisschen umzudrehen, weil in meinem Kopf löst diese Frage ja eine Gegenfrage aus. Ist das nicht bei jedem Buch so, dass wir uns ständig bei jeder Seite fragen, ist das notwendig oder braucht man das oder braucht man jenes? Das ist ja derjenige, der es aufschreibt oder derjenige, der diese Dinge erlebt hat, der denkt sich ja etwas dabei oder der empfindet diese Information als notwendig. Für mich – ich habe ja genau diesen Teil mit Marie geschrieben – für mich war es notwendig, diese Passage mit reinzuschreiben, weil ich fand, dass diese Passage für ein Element gesprochen hat in dem Moment, weil bis zu dem Moment, als Marie an die Tür gekommen ist, gab es den früheren John im Prinzip nicht. Bis zu diesem Moment war John ein echtes Nervenbündel und für mich nicht erkennbar als der Entertainer, als auch der Mensch, der mit sehr viel Humor, auch ein bisschen mit seinem Schlawinertum Menschen begegnet ist. Und das endete sich ab dem Moment, als Marie die Tür aufgemacht hat. Deshalb muss ich als Autor ja irgendwie Marie mit einführen. Ich muss erklären, wer sie ist, was sie tut. Ob man am Ende erklären muss, wie sie riecht, weiß ich nicht. Es ist mir aber etwas, was mir im Gedächtnis geblieben ist und für mich irgendwie auch so einen Auslöser dafür hatte, warum er vielleicht sich in dem Moment gerade auch ein bisschen, in Anführungsstrichen lockerer gemacht hat. Er sieht eine junge Frau vor sich, die sehr nett wirkt, die nicht abweisend wirkt und das in einer totalen Stresssituation. Man muss ja bedenken, wir sind dort zum ersten Mal bei seinem Anwalt und auf John kommt am nächsten Tag das große erste Verhör bei den französischen Behörden zu. Und dann öffnet ihm völlig unerwartet eine junge Frau die Tür und auf einmal verändert sich etwas im Wesenszug dieses Whistleblowers, dieses Informanten, der dann auf einmal anfängt wieder mit ihr zu shakern, zu lachen und in Muster verfällt, die ich eigentlich von ihm kenne. Mit solchen Elementen habe ich ja häufiger im Buch gespielt. Das hat für mich, finde ich, nichts mit einer Roman-Darstellung zu tun, sondern das hat etwas mit dem Aufbau einer Figur zu tun.
Ja, das liegt natürlich in der Freiheit des Autors. Vielleicht haben wir da alle auch einen anderen Blick darauf. Da schließe ich mich ausdrücklich mit ein durch das, was mit Klaas Relotius reinkam in die Debatte rund um die Darstellung von Journalismus. Bevor wir aber dieses Fass an der Stelle aufmachen, würde ich sagen, hängen wir uns nicht an stilistischen Fragen auf, sondern lass uns nochmal zurückkommen zu den neuen Enthüllungen. Du hast ein paar davon schon genannt, ein paar davon hat man auch schon außerhalb dieses Buches Football Leaks 2 mitbekommen. Was würdest du denn sagen, waren so die drei wichtigsten Entdeckungen, die ihr im Material gehabt habt, die auch dann eine Auswirkung hatten auf die Fußballwelt? Was würdest du da rauspecken?
Bezogen nur auf Football Leaks 2 oder generell auf die Football Leaks?
Lass mal mit Football Leaks 2 starten, dann können wir es ja gerne noch im weiteren Kontext uns angucken.
Damit meinst du nicht nur das Buch, sondern auch die Veröffentlichungswelle im November, richtig? Genau. Bestritten ist, glaube ich, die stärkste Enthüllung gewesen, dass wir aufgezeigt haben, wie sowohl Manchester City als auch Paris Saint-Germain über Jahre die Regularien des Financial Fairplays nicht nur umgehen, sondern sie auch sehr bewusst verletzen, brechen, auch wenn sie selbst bis heute ja entweder ausschweigen oder es verneinen. Aber die Atemweise, also die Brutalität, mit der sie in den Markt hineingegangen sind als Investorenclubs und sich eben an die gültigen Spielregeln kaum gehalten haben und das alles auch noch mit tätiger Mithilfe der Verbände. Ich erinnere an die Geschichte rund um Gianni Infantino und seine Verstrickung in die Verhandlungen rund um die Financial Fair Play Settlements. Das zeigt, finde ich, sehr deutlich, wie stark der Markt gekippt ist, wie stark auch die Grundverhältnisse im Markt gekippt sind. Und wenn man dagegen hält, wie die Traditionsclubs in Anführungsstrichen, also Clubs, die seit Jahren auch im Spitzenfußball vertreten sind oder in der Champions League vertreten sind, wie sie sich dagegen gestellt haben, gestemmt haben, wie sie in klandestinen Gruppen versucht haben, die Wafer zu erpressen, um mehr Geld dazu bekommen, um eben auch diesen Investoren über Macht Paroli bieten zu können. Das war für mich eigentlich so das Beeindruckendste, dass das Ganze dann natürlich weitergeht und in den, so oft wie es bei kaputten Branchen ist, in den Rändern dann eigentlich das Spannendste wird. Wenn man sehen konnte, dass der ermittelnde Oberstaatsanwalt in der Schweiz über die Football-Leaks am Ende gestolpert ist, weil klar wurde, dass er mehrere Treffen mit Gianni Infantino gehabt hat, die nirgendwo protokolliert waren, die nirgendwo aufgetaucht sind gegen alle Ermittlungsregeln. Das sind dann so Punkte, bei denen ich dann auch feststelle, wie wenig wir eigentlich auch über die Aufklärungsarbeit wissen, wie sehr wir oftmals auch das Machtverhältnis der Verbände überschätzen, die eigentlich überhaupt keine Kontrolle mehr über den Spitzenfußball haben. Das sieht man dann auch, wenn man sich die vielen, vielen Enthüllungen zum Jugendspielerbereich anguckt, die wir veröffentlicht haben, wie vollkommen unkontrolliert dieser Bereich mittlerweile abläuft. Dass große Clubs wie Manchester City an Dreiecksgeschäfte zwischen einer afrikanischen Akademie und einem dänischen Club betreiben, dass die Spieler zwischenparken, dass die Spieler in großem Maße holen aus prekären Lebenssituationen und am Ende quasi auf den einen Blue-Chip setzen, alles andere wird verliehen oder irgendwann werden Verträge danach auslaufen gelassen und die Spieler sind sich dann wieder selbst überlassen. Das ist beim FC Chelsea sogar noch eindringlicher. Mittlerweile haben ja beide Clubs auch ihre Untersuchungen bzw. Strafen dafür zum Teil erhalten, also Transfersperren erhalten. Aber das zu sehen, dass es dort überhaupt keine Pufferzonen gibt und es ging ja so weit, dass wir auf einmal herausgefunden haben, dass es eine illegale Spielliga in England gibt, der Spitzenclubs, die sich dort organisieren und die Jugendspieler ohne Anmeldung spielen lassen oder gegeneinander antreten lassen.
Die können mit den Spielpraxis sammeln, obwohl sie offiziell gar nicht bei diesem Club spielen durften, weil sie noch zu jung sind.
Genau. Da bleibt man einfach fassungslos vorstehen. Man fragt sich die ganze Zeit, was ist eigentlich mit diesen Spielern, wenn sie mit 12, 13 Jahren weggekauft werden und dann vier, fünf Jahre in keiner offiziellen Liga irgendwo auftauchen, nicht gemeldet sind, weil sie eben nicht gemeldet werden dürfen, weil sie noch zu jung sind, weil ihre Eltern nicht mit umziehen können. Und man dann auf einmal feststellt, die spielen ja jedes Wochenende immer noch gegeneinander. Das ist so ein bisschen wie ausgesperrter immer bei uns. Dann macht man halt für diejenigen einen eigenen Sektor. Das ist nicht mehr mit normalen Maßstäben, glaube ich, zu verstehen, weil da in dem Moment natürlich auch weder die FIFA noch die UEFA so richtig Einflussgebiet hatte oder hat. Und jetzt beim Buch der TV-Markt, der dann nochmal mit dazu kam. Wir haben uns im zweiten Buch die Frage gestellt, wie es denn so weit kommen konnte, dass der Fußball so dermaßen gekippt ist, dass die Fußballbranche so außer Kontrolle geraten ist. Und haben uns dafür auch mit dem Einfluss des TV-Markts auf den Fußball beschäftigt, einfach um festzustellen, wo kommt das Geld her, wie wird das Geld dort verteilt. Weil das ist ja nochmal das Geld, das wir alle bezahlen, um keine Ahnung, die TV bezahlt sind dazu, quer so subventionieren, wie man es so nennen möchte. Und das ist das Geld, das am Ende in dem Sport landet, was am Ende in dem Sport Eingang findet. Also ja, damit haben wir uns sehr ausführlich beschäftigt und dort eben festgestellt, dass ich glaube, dass dieser Bereich bis zum Schluss noch nicht mal ansatzweise aus den Mitteln ist.
Wobei das ja auch tatsächlich jetzt noch keine neue Erkenntnis ist, also dass viel der Korruption im Fußball über TV-Rechte stattfindet, das hat man ja rund um den FIFA-Prozess schon sehr gut herausgearbeitet bekommen. Dazu gibt es schon viele andere Quellen, gerade im südamerikanischen Verband ist da viel auch aufgedeckt worden. Also man wusste quasi schon, was da passiert ist. Es sind jetzt quasi neue Facetten mit dazu gekommen. Jetzt geht es bei euch unter anderem um die TV-Rechte der kasachischen Nationalmannschaft und wie mit denen dann gediert wurde. Aber das Grundthema war bekannt.
Vor allem geht es aber auch um den Einfluss von mindestens zwei Deutschen. Bislang war es ja immer so, dass man gesagt hat, dieser schmuddelige TV-Markt irgendwo in Südamerika oder in der Schweiz von irgendwelchen dubiosen Leuten betrieben. Und dann wirft man eben einen Blick in eine solche Firma wie Kentaro und stellt fest, dass sich das Deutsche dort einen ganz großen Rat mitgedreht haben und das über Jahre. Und das haben wir versucht mit aufzureißen, weil zumindest dieser Deal, der Kentaro-Deal, also dieser Kasachstan-Deal, der ja auch die öffentlich-rechtlichen mitbetrifft, bislang in der Öffentlichkeit überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt hat.
Und dann gibt es noch ein neues Element, würde ich sagen, jetzt in Football Leaks 2, nämlich Match Fixing und zwar die pervertierteste Form von Match Fixing und zwar insofern, dass sich einfach ein Investor, Mao Xiaodong, ein oder zwei Clubs mehr oder weniger einverleibt und dann dort eine nennenswerte Anzahl an Spielern dann eben einfach beeinflussen kann. Es geht jetzt um Athlantown und um Atletico CP. Und das ist ja noch so ein bisschen ein neuer Bereich, der jetzt mit den Football Leaks 2 mit aufkam. Ich hatte das Gefühl, das ging fast ein bisschen unter, auch in der Rezeption jetzt des Buches. Wie ist da deine Haltung zu?
Naja, ich glaube generell, dass wir mit Football Leaks 2 ein deutlich breiteres Spektrum der problematischen Felder im Fußball ausleuchten, als es noch im ersten Football Leaks Projekt der Fall war. Beim ersten Football Leaks Projekt haben wir uns sehr stark auf Steuerhinterziehung, auf die Image Rights und auch die Problemfelder der Beraterszene fokussiert. Hier haben wir jetzt diesmal ja nicht nur Match Fixing, sondern wir beschäftigen uns am Rand auch mit der Möglichkeit von Doping bzw. von medizinischen Hilfsproblemen. Wir beschäftigen uns eben mit dem Jugendspielerbereich, wir beschäftigen uns mit dem TV-Markt, mit Stiftung und Stiftungsgeld. Es kommt der Vorwurf der Vergewaltigung gegen Cristiano Ronaldo, wird lang behandelt. Zum Match Fixing selbst, das ist eine Recherche, die aus dem Jahr 2017 stammt, die Federführung mein Kollege Tim Rhön gemacht hat, der mittlerweile bei der Welt ist, aber damals eben noch bei uns. Wir haben uns für die Geschichte ziemlich viel bewegt, weil wir festgestellt haben, dass es Firmen gibt, die das Match Fixing im Fußball sehr stark monitorn und sich damit beschäftigen. Das kannten wir schon seit Jahren und wir wussten das seit Jahren. Wir hatten aber jetzt eben auch in den Football Leaks Dokumente, die uns das aufgezeigt haben und die uns vor allem diese Querverbindungen aufgezeigt haben. Als wir dann, als Tim dann in Portugal unterwegs war und festgestellt hat, dass dieser Verein wirklich eine Handpuppe eines Investors war und die Ergebnisse alle in einer Art und Weise für nicht wirklich sauberen Fußball gesprochen haben, inklusive der Fans, die dort Sturm gelaufen sind, die uns dann erzählt haben, wie sie auf der Tribüne gesessen haben und Nachrichten von Wettanbietern bekommen haben, die sie auf ein Tor hingewiesen haben, was aber erst Minuten später gefallen ist.
Man konnte es daran erkennen, dass sich ein Spieler in die Abwehr hat fallen lassen. Das war ein bisschen das Zeichen an die Mannschaft.
Exakt, genau. Ein Vogel, wilder Torwart, der einfach nach vorne gerannt ist, ohne Sinn und Verstand. Und dann hinterher, als er mit den Vorwürfen konfrontiert wurde, gesagt hat, wenn ich ein guter Torwart wäre, würde ich für Real Madrid spielen und nicht hier.
Und das ist der Torhüter, der immer bei den Vereinen von Mao Xiaodong im Tor stand.
Das war halt auch das interessante, das wir sehen konnten, dass es eine richtige Migration von Menschen, die verdächtigt werden, Spiele zu manipulieren, gegeben hat. Also die von einem Club zum anderen transferiert wurden. Und sobald sie dann bei dem neuen Club angekommen sind, die gleichen Vorwürfe gegen sie erhoben wurden, wie bei den Clubs vorher auch. Und nachdem der portugiesische Club dann ja auch diese Katastrophensaison gespielt hat und nahezu alles verloren hat, wofür der Club eins gestanden hat, sind all diese Spieler und die handelnden Personen dahinter, haben den Club verlassen. Die sind weg. Die Handpuppe ist in sich zusammengefallen. Es gab keine Hand mehr da drin. Der Club ist im Prinzip ausgehöhlt worden und ist sich jetzt selbst überlassen. Aber auch das ist im Übrigen kein völlig neues Situation. Wir hatten schon im Jahr 2011, dass wir zum Beispiel in Belgien den Club Namur hatten, der damals von Wettbetrügern aus Deutschland unterwandert war. Die dort in dem Verein als Investoren eingestiegen sind, dann peu a peu ihre eigenen Spieler in den Club gebracht haben und dann angefangen haben, gegen den Club zu spielen. Weil sie auch Niederlagen des Clubs gewettet haben bzw. auf sehr hohe Toranzahlen, die der Club kassieren sollte, gewettet haben und dann ihre Gewinne gemacht haben durch die Wettquoten bzw. durch die Wettverläufe. Das ist eine, wenn man so möchte, die härteste Schattenseite der Kommerzialisierung des Fußballs, weil mittlerweile in so kleinen Clubs ist es sehr einfach mit hohen Wettgewinnen im Prinzip mehr zu verdienen als mit den Prämien oder mit den Errungenschaften, die ein solcher Club haben könnte, wenn er ganz normal erfolgreich in einer Liga spielen würde.
Der unsaubere Weg zum Geld ist manchmal der leichtere Weg. Wenn ich mir jetzt den Gesamtkontext eurer Bücher angucke und eben jetzt auch Football Leaks 1 mit einbeziehe, dann ist mir vor allem aufgefallen, dass ihr im ersten Buch noch sehr viele Summen genannt habt, dass es sehr viel darum geht, wie viel ein Spieler an Prämien allein mit einem verwandelten Elfmeter verdienen kann. Da ging es viel darum, die Dimension aufzuzeigen, die sich eben einfach von der Lebenswelt, die du und ich haben, dann dahingehend unterscheidet, dass da Summen im Umlauf sind, die wir in unserem Leben nicht verdienen werden. Und im zweiten Buch fehlt dieser Teil ein bisschen und es geht auch weniger um den moralischen Aspekt dieses Fußballgeschäfts. War das eine bewusste Entscheidung? Wie würdest du diesen Unterschied in den beiden Büchern erklären?
Ich glaube, um ehrlich zu sein, das Jahr 2017 hat da maximale Auswirkungen auf uns gehabt. Wir haben ja, als wir mit den Football Leaks angefangen haben, war das für uns auch eine völlige Neuheit. Wir haben zu dem Zeitpunkt natürlich gewusst, dass der Fußball viel Geld umgesetzt wird. Wir haben aber nicht gewusst, wie dieses Geld zirkuliert. Wir haben zu dem Zeitpunkt uns unklar, wie hoch die Abkupplung des Beraterwesens vom normalen Fußballkreislauf ist. Wir waren dort das erste Mal konfrontiert mit der Anzahl der vielen Klauseln, die es ermöglichen, Geld zu maximieren, wie es ansonsten nur an der Börse möglich wäre. All dies war Bestandteil, zumal wir sehr schnell festgestellt haben, dass viele der Gelder unsauber abgerechnet weitergeleitet werden. Ich habe irgendwann den Satz gesagt, dass ich bei Football Leaks 1 das Gefühl hatte, dass zu jedem Spitzenfußballer auch eine Briefkastenfirma in einer Steueroase dazugehören muss. Dort sind wir dann sehr tief reingegangen, um den Versuch zu unternehmen, dem Leser zu erklären, dass die Gelder, die der Zuschauer, der normale Fan in den Fußball hineinpumpt, dass viele von diesen Geldern relativ Zeit nach Europa verlassen und mit Steuersparmodellen irgendwo auf den British Virgin Islands, irgendwo in Irland, in Hollandischen Klitschen, in Asien, in der Karibik versickern und verschwinden und oftmals erst nach dem Karriereende von Spitzenfußballern wieder nach Europa zurücktransferiert werden, aber dann oftmals sehr klandestin auf irgendwelche Privatkonten in der Schweiz oder in Luxemburg oder Lichtenstein. Das war ein sehr wichtiger Ansatz für uns damals, um diese Tragweite und Fallhöhen des Geldes zu erläutern. Dann kam eben das Jahr 2017 mit dem Neymar-Transfer, der alles pulverisierte, was wir bis dahin ja auch geschrieben hatten. Wir dachten bis zum Sommer 2017, dass der Fußball jetzt vollkommen irre wird und sind dann von unserer eigenen Prophezeiung eingeholt oder überholt worden, als Neymar für 220 Millionen gewechselt ist. Und dann war irgendwann auch so ein Punkt für uns da, an dem wir gesagt haben, der Leser weiß jetzt viel darüber. Der Leser hat das jetzt verstanden. Der Leser hat jetzt verstanden, wie entkoppelt auch diese Branche finanziell funktioniert. Was der Leser am Ende daraus macht, ist seine eigene Entscheidung oder was die Gesellschaft daraus macht, ist ihre eigene Entscheidung. Das gilt ja nicht nur für den Leser, sondern das gilt ja auch für Politiker, das gilt für Verbände, die in irgendeiner Form darauf reagieren sollten, reagieren möglicherweise müssten, aber was sie müssen, entscheiden sie am Ende auch selbst. Und wir haben uns dann irgendwann einfach angeguckt, welche Breite die Daten sonst haben, welche thematischen Felder dort sonst interessant sein könnten, um ein vollständiges Bild des Fußballgeschäfts zeichnen zu können. Vollständig ist jetzt ein zu großer Begriff, aber zumindest ein umfassenderes Bild des Fußballgeschäfts zeichnen zu können. Und so sind wir dann auch im zweiten Buch auf viele der anderen Bereiche gekommen, über die ich gerade gesprochen habe.
Apropos vollständiges Bild und Menge der Daten, was hat sich denn da getan? Ich weiß, dass wir am Anfang noch viel versucht haben, Terabyte in Relation zu setzen. Dann ging es darum, wie oft das die Bibel ist. Die Bibel ist ja quasi das Saarland des geschriebenen Wortes. Was hat sich denn mit den Datenmengen verändert jetzt in den letzten Jahren bis hin zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir jetzt miteinander sprechen?
Wir haben aufgehört, Relationsgrößen zu bestimmen, weil die Anzahl der Daten einfach so groß geworden ist, dass es aus unserer Sicht keine Relationsgrößen mehr dazu gibt. Wir haben mittlerweile deutlich über 70 Millionen Dokumente, die in Datenbestand sind. Und das sind nur die Kerndokumente aus Football Leaks. Das sind noch nicht die Dokumente, mit denen wir Football Leaks matchen. Also die Handelsregister, Firmenregister, die Personalregister – all das, was wir als zweite Datenebene dort noch mit nutzen. Dafür gibt es keine Bezugsgröße. Bei über 70 Millionen Dokumenten ist es einfach klar, dass es mehr ist, indem wir auch immer wieder aufs Neue versinken. Wir haben jetzt gerade eine Recherche zu einem völlig anderen Thema, indem wir wieder in den Football Leaks dann auch suchen, weil das mittlerweile so ein bisschen wie so ein Lexikon geworden ist. Jedes fußballbezogene Thema, das wir haben, versuchen wir dann natürlich auch nochmal mit den Football Leaks abzugleichen und zu gucken. Gibt es dort noch in irgendeiner Form weiterführende Information? Gibt es etwas, was möglicherweise unseren Rechercheansatz stärkt? Gibt es eine zweite Quelle? Gibt es Personen, die sich über dieses Thema irgendwann mal unterhalten haben?
Und kennzeichnet ihr das dann, wenn ihr in anderen Artikeln mithilfe von Football Leaks Material gearbeitet habt?
Wenn wir Football Leaks nutzen, dann steht das auch in der Regel in den Texten drin.
Wie hinderlich waren denn dann technische Grenzen beim Auswerten dieser 80 Millionen Dokumente?
Da sind sie bis heute. Die technischen Grenzen waren insbesondere hinderlich, weil wir festgestellt haben, dass unsere Servergrößen irgendwann an Anschlag gekommen sind. Wir konnten, insbesondere als wir dann Anfang 2018 nochmal diesen sehr großen Schwung der Dokumente von Football Leaks bekommen haben, haben wir festgestellt, dass wir dort technisch noch nicht ausgestattet waren. Wir wollten eigentlich mit der Auswertung viel früher beginnen und wurden dann über mehrere Monate daran gehindert, ordnungsgemäß zu starten, weil die Programme, insbesondere der Indizierungsvorgang, also das Überspielen der Daten von den originalen Festplatten auf unsere internen Systeme immer wieder abgebrochen sind. Der ist immer wieder abgeschmiert, weil es so viele unterschiedliche Dateien gab und vor allem die schiere Masse der Dokumente dazu geführt hat. Wir haben ja zwei Indizierungsprozesse. Das ist einmal das Überspielen auf unsere internen Server und dann eben das Aufspielen auf die Server, die dann für unsere europäischen Partner zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Das heißt, beide Indizierungsprozesse müssen ordnungsgemäß ablaufen und da haben wir dann zahlreiche Bugs festgestellt und eben auch festgestellt, dass manche Daten nicht mit übertragen wurden und wir dann nochmal nacharbeiten mussten. Und jetzt aktuell haben wir wieder ein technisches Problem, weil wir einfach unser System nochmal verändert haben, auf ein anderes System umgestellt haben. Und dieses System jetzt so verdammt langsam ist, dass wir im Moment alle die Haare raufen und überlegen, wie wir das hinbekommen. Wir haben wunderbare Techniker auch hier im Haus. Wir haben mittlerweile jemanden, Stefan Hefner, der sich ausschließlich als ITler für das Investigative oder mit dem Investigativen beschäftigt, der uns dauerhaft zur Verfügung steht. Das ist eine wahnsinnige Erleichterung. Im EIC gibt es zwei Kollegen, die rund um die Uhr damit zu tun haben. Das hilft schon immens. Von uns Journalisten ist keiner in der Lage, irgendeines dieser Probleme selbstständig zu lösen. Wie auch. Das sind technische Dinge, die deutlich über das hinausgehen, was wir gelernt haben, was wir können.
Warum kennt sich Rui Pinto so gut in den Dokumenten aus? Wenn ihr schon Probleme habt, sie alleine durchsuchbar zu machen. Du beschilterst das ja auch in den Büchern, dass er zum Teil Passagen aus E-Mails noch rezitieren kann. Wie erklärst du dir das?
Schwierig zu sagen. Was man festhalten kann, ist, dass er tatsächlich ein wahnsinniger Autodidakt ist. Das haben uns mehrere Quellen bestätigt. Dass er sich das Lesen und das Schreiben selbst beigebracht hat. Er konnte mit vier Jahren schon schreiben. Er hat mal für seine Schulbibliothek eigenständig eine Art Indizierungsverfahren programmiert, mit dem alle Bücher erfasst wurden. Ich weiß es nicht. Er ist ja irgendwo auch so eine Mischung zwischen Entertainer und völliger Nerd. Ich war manchmal erschrocken, wenn ich auf eine Recherche eingegangen bin. Ich habe versucht, ihm nicht so stark einen Einblick zu geben, an welchen Recherchen wir gerade sitzen. Aber manchmal geht es einfach nicht anders. Man muss ihm sagen, dass wir uns als Grobkennziffer mit dem Financial Fair Play beschäftigen. Er hat schon wochenlang mit mir über das Financial Fair Play gesprochen. Wenn er aus dem Nichts heraus, wie du es gerade sagst, rezipieren konnte, dann musst du mal diese oder jene Mail oder dieses Dokument angucken. Das hat mich beeindruckt, weil ich mir diese Sachen so noch nicht mal im Kopf hätte merken können. Ich war jeden Tag damit beschäftigt und er hat teilweise bis in Monate zwischenvergangen, dass wir die Dokumente erhalten haben und zwischen der Tatsache, dass wir uns dann über eines dieser Themen unterhalten haben. Und er war trotzdem total im Film.
Könnte das vielleicht ein Hinweis darauf sein, dass er sehr genau ausgesucht hat, was er euch übergeben hat?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, dass sich jemand das so aussuchen kann. Da ist meine Vorstellungsgabe einfach beschränkt, weil dafür sind die Dokumente zu vielschichtig. Sie haben eine zu große Streuung. Sie sind nicht fokussiert auf einen Bereich. Sie haben nicht einen elementaren Strang, sondern sie sind sehr, sehr ungeordnet. Wir haben ja oftmals erst die Ordnung durch die Auswertung mit reingebracht. Wir standen oftmals vor den Daten und wussten überhaupt nicht, wo wir anfangen sollen, weil sie thematisch eben keine Klarheit hatten. Ich werde niemals meine Hände für irgendjemanden ins Feuer legen, weil das das Dümste ist, was ein investigativer Journalist machen könnte. Das werde ich auch in diesem Fall nicht machen. Aber ich kann es mir einfach aus der schieren Menge und Vielschichtigkeit der Daten nicht vorstellen, dass irgendjemand zielgerichtet sich diese Sachen angucken konnte. Ohne diese technischen Mittel, die wir dafür haben. Und die hatte er nicht.
Wie viele Personen im Spiegel haben den Zugriff auf das volle Football Leaks Archiv?
Ich glaube, es sind neun.
Und die können alle alles suchen. Und betrifft das dann auch die europäischen Recherchepartner? Weil du das jetzt gerade nochmal angesprochen hattest, vorher mit den zwei unterschiedlichen Serverinstanzen, die ihr da habt, haben die auch den Vollzugriff?
Ja, komplett. Und können sich das gesamte Material angucken.
Und werden irgendwann auch mal andere deutschen Medien zugreifen dürfen? Oder bleibt das jetzt der Schatz des Spiegel quasi?
Am Ende obliegt das Rui Pinto. Das ist nicht unsere Entscheidung. Also was wir natürlich nicht tun werden, ist, die Daten, die wir haben, anderen zugänglich machen. Das wäre unter dem Gesichtspunkt einer Konkurrenz zwischen Medienhäusern, glaube ich, auch für niemanden wirklich sinnvoll. Es gibt auch noch einen anderen Grund, warum wir diese Daten zum Beispiel nicht öffentlich machen. Aus unserer Sicht betreffen diese Daten ja zahlreiche, sehr private Felder, die in der Öffentlichkeit überhaupt nicht zu suchen haben. Also die Sozialversicherungsnummer, die Adresse, die möglicherweise Liebschaften.
Aber die könntet ihr ja auch schwarzen. Also ihr müsst jetzt ja nicht alle Daten veröffentlichen, aber dass ihr jetzt in so vielen Seiten Football Leaks kein einziges Originaldokument zitiert, fand ich schon erstaunlich. Ihr könnt ja dann trotzdem da solche sozialen Daten rauszunehmen.
Da muss ich einhaken. Wir haben zigmal Originaldokumente aus den Football Leaks gezeigt oder dargestellt. Ich erinnere an den Fall Majorga gegen Ronaldo.
Das stimmt, online.
Wir haben die Sachen ja auch im Heft abgedruckt bzw. paraffrasiert und gezeigt. Das haben wir sehr oft gemacht bei Geschichten. Vor allem auch dann, wenn es Widerstand zu den Geschichten gegeben hat, sind wir oftmals noch in einer zweiten Rutsche, haben wir die Dokumente gezeigt und nachvollziehbar gemacht. Das führte ja auch im Endeffekt bei Manchester City dazu. Das Zeigen der Dokumente führte dazu, dass die UEFA am Ende auch dieses Verfahren aufgenommen hat.
Jetzt gibt es aber ja, du hast jetzt angesprochen, die Konkurrenz an den Medienhäusern. Das ist ja klar und wir bewegen uns ja hier nicht in einem luftleeren ideellen Raum, in dem der Spiegel auch seine Ressourcen einfach so von Gott geschenkt bekommt, mit denen er das Ganze auch finanzieren kann. Und trotzdem gab es hier auch Vorwürfe von anderen Medien, manchmal unterschwellig, manchmal offener formuliert, bezüglich fehlender Transparenz von eurer Seite. Und eben, du hast recht, online wurden Originaldokumente veröffentlicht, in den Büchern jetzt aber zum Beispiel fehlt das. Da wird dann immer nur zitiert. Wie siehst du denn das, was der Spiegel jetzt mit den Football Leaks macht, in der deutschen Medienlandschaft verortet, im Verhältnis zu anderen Medien? Ist das wirklich nur eine Konkurrenz? Könnte es nicht auch eine inhaltliche Kooperation sein?
Den letzten Teil der Frage verstehe ich nicht, aber da komme ich gleich nochmal darauf zurück. Was ich bislang nicht festgestellt habe, ist, dass uns Medien vorwerfen, wir würden nicht genug Transparenz walten lassen. Was sie uns unterschwellig immer wieder vorgeworfen haben, ist die Frage, warum wir mit Rui Pinto zu tun haben und sonst mit keinem anderen offenbar zu tun hat. Was ich auch dahingestellt lasse, ob es wirklich so ist oder nicht so ist, aber dass uns ein Mangel an Transparenz vorgehalten wurde, das habe ich zumindest als Angriff und es gibt viele Angriffe auf uns, aber den Angriff habe ich bislang noch nicht vernommen. Wo soll der hergekommen sein?
Ja gut, dann lass es mich umformulieren. Das kann dann nämlich auch so ein bisschen den Teil der Frage, den du nicht verstanden hast, erklären. Zum Beispiel rund um die Super League Veröffentlichungen, das zitiert er ja auch nochmal in eurem Buch, das war der erfolgreichste Spiegeltitel 2018. Da gab es unter anderem von Seiten von Thomas Gistner aus Richtung der Süddeutschen Zeitung den Vorwurf, im Grunde sei das alles schon bekannt gewesen. Ähnlich hat sich dann auch der FC Bayern geäußert. Und da habe ich mich gefragt, ob nicht das für den Leser, einfach jetzt aus Sicht des naiven Lesers, das konstruktivere gewesen wäre, ihr hättet euch mit euren Rechercheergebnissen in diesem einen Thema zusammengetan. Thomas Kistner und die Kollegen der Süddeutschen Zeitung und Kolleginnen hatten dazu recherchiert. Ihr hattet erstmalig noch neue Informationen, die vor allem E-Mail-Kontakte von Seiten des FC Bayern waren, E-Mails und so weiter Nachrichten. Da hätte man doch an der Stelle eigentlich auch ganz gut eine ergänzende Berichterstattung machen können.
Die Frage richtet sich ja eher an Thomas Kistner als an mich, um ehrlich zu sein. Wir haben ja dann wenige Monate später Thomas Kistner ja nochmal zur Super League geschrieben und war dann auf einmal völlig überrascht, dass es offenbar doch zu einem Treffen zwischen dem FC Bayern und Real Madrid gekommen ist, kurz vor unserer Veröffentlichung. Und es dort offenbar sehr wohl Thema war, über die Super League zu sprechen. Herr Kistner hat dann sehr schnell einen offenbar netten Brief vom Anfall des FC Bayern bekommen, der keine weiteren Fragen dazu erhalten wollte bzw. beantworten wollte. Und hat seine eigene, also dann die Darstellung im Prinzip auf unseren Erkenntnissen aus dem November 2018 nochmal gestützt und dort für uns netterweise dann auch sauber zitiert, ausnahmsweise.
Aber weißt du, genau diese Zwischentöne sind so ein bisschen…
Naja, ich bin natürlich auch genervt davon. Selbstverständlich bin ich genervt davon. Klar hätte ich mir gewünscht, dass eine solche Geschichte, wenn wir sie rezipieren, wenn wir sie aufschreiben und wenn wir darstellen, dass es sehr wohl Bedenken von den Vereinen gegeben hat, dass es Bemühungen von den Vereinen im Jahr 2016 gegeben hat, eine Super League zu gründen, die dann so weit gegangen sind, dass die Vereine bei der UEFA im Prinzip für sich Gelder erpresst haben, die den Markt in ein noch größeres Ungleichgewicht bringen und das jetzt einfach für das Jahr 2018 und bis 2021 die folgenden Jahre große Auswirkungen hat. Und dieses Radkasten nicht mehr eingefangen. Dass wir uns dann klar wünschen würden von einem solchen absoluten Recherche-Experten, wie es Thomas Kistner auch ist, den ich wahnsinnig schätze im Übrigen für all das, was er zu FIFA in den vergangenen Jahren auch herausgefunden hat. Dass das entsprechend dann auch eingeordnet wird, statt dann, keine Ahnung, mit der Nase zu rumpfen und zu sagen, es ist alles alt, weil wir es gerade nicht haben. Das ist ja, aber ich glaube, das sind auch so blöde Medienspiele beziehungsweise so blöde – Metathemen. Ja, wir haben eine blöde Medienkonkurrenz gehasselt, dass das ständig da ist, bei dem ich mir ehrlicherweise einfach wünschen würde, dass man es lässt. Aber ich habe es auch in den letzten Jahren nicht anders erlebt als auf diese Art und Weise. Und da will ich uns, um ehrlich zu sein, gar nicht freisprechen. Ich glaube, dass das bei uns auch oft genug passiert ist, dass wir möglicherweise die Themen von Dritten gar nicht so gewürdigt oder eingeordnet haben, weil wir andere Informationen dazu hatten, als es die Kollegen getan haben. Zu deiner Frage, warum man sich da nicht zusammentut, die Antwort ist ja relativ einfach. Weil wir zu dem Zeitpunkt gar nicht wissen, dass Thomas Kistner auch an dieser Geschichte recherchiert. Dass wir gar nicht wissen, dass andere Medien da recherchieren. Woher sollen wir das wissen? Wir beschäftigen uns ja mit unserer eigenen Recherche und haben hier keine Themenkonferenz aller Medienhäuser. Es ist ja schon so, dass wir uns auch sehr bewusst darauf achten, dass es eine Medienpluralität in Deutschland gibt und dass die Medienhäuser auch immer noch unabhängig voneinander arbeiten. Ich persönlich finde es wichtig, auch mal bei bestimmten Dingen zu kooperieren. Unsere Kooperation aktuell zu Football Leaks mit dem NDR war, finde ich, für alle Seiten eine sehr wichtige und richtige Entscheidung, weil wir dadurch sowohl Tiefe als auch Reichweite in die Themen bekommen haben. Aber es ist immer noch für mich so, dass diese Art der Kooperation im breiten Feld eher die Ausnahme bleiben sollte. Es ist schon, glaube ich, auch etwas Gutes, wenn Medien kritisch auch aufeinander gucken und nicht nur gemeinsam versuchen, Dinge zu tun.
Valider Punkt. Bevor wir uns dann in so medientheoretischen Diskussionen verlieren, wobei ich auch darüber noch ewig mit dir sprechen könnte, ich muss aber auch ein bisschen auf die Zeit gucken. Deswegen lass da mal zu dem kommen, was am meisten für Aufruhr gesorgt hat, du hast es ja vorhin auch schon selber angesprochen, nämlich die Enttarnung von John und das Bekanntwerden, dass wir hier mit Rui Pedro Goncalves Pinto es zu tun haben. Wer wusste denn jetzt alles von der Identität innerhalb des Spieges? In Football League 1 hieß es noch nur du wusstest die Identität, in 2 hieß es dann, es gab so eine kleine Reihe von Personen.
Beides ist korrekt und schließt sich nicht aus. Am Anfang kannte ich nur die Identität, aber auch um mich selbst zu schützen, habe ich irgendwann auch mit Rui Pinto besprochen, dass ich meine Chefredaktion, meine Rechtsabteilung und auch einen Teil meiner Ressortleiter mit einweihe, wohin ich fliege und mit wem ich es da eigentlich zu tun habe, wo die Person herkommt. Das war notwendig auch, damit ich selbst Abstand bekomme bzw. Distanzen bekomme und auch mit jemandem mal drüber reden konnte, wie ich Rui Pinto wahrgenommen habe und welche Zweifel möglicherweise ich auch habe, welche Wege man da einschlagen soll oder nicht einschlagen soll. Deshalb war dieser kleine Kreis hier beim Spiegel, mit dem ich sehr oft über Rui Pinto diskutiert habe und das auch hier in diesem kleinen Kreis geblieben ist.
Unser letztes Gespräch war am 13. November 2018. Und da kommen wir zu einer Kleinigkeit. Oder ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Kleinigkeit ist. Im letzten Tribünengespräch fiel schon der Name Rui Pinto. Im Nachgespräch hast du mich gebeten oder versucht, dahin zu bewegen, dass ich den Namen rausnehme. Das habe ich dann tatsächlich auch getan. Das war meine freie Entscheidung. Mit der ich jetzt im Nachhinein logischerweise nicht mehr so ganz glücklich bin. Wie aktiv sollte denn ein Journalist beim Quellenschutz sein? Warum hast du das damals gemacht?
Na ja, es ging ja darum, dass du mich danach gefragt hast. Und ich selbst habe dich damals darum gebeten, dass nicht klar werden sollte, dass ich mich irgendwie zu Rui Pinto äußere. Das ist natürlich der Quellenschutz gewesen.
Wobei ich dich nicht gebracht hatte, ob es okay ist, den Namen zu nennen. Also wir haben danach nochmal darüber gesprochen.
Genau.
Und du hast mir noch viele Hintergrundinformationen zu der Veröffentlichung des Sabado gegeben, die für mich dann auch schwer nachzuprüfen waren, weil ich einfach des Portugiesischens nicht mächtig bin. Das ist aber sowieso ein grundlegendes Problem bei den Football Leaks, wenn man das nicht kann. Und die Medienlandschaft in Portugal ist auch eine sehr eigene.
Na du hast es gerade auch ein bisschen verkürzt dargestellt, weil soweit ich mich erinnere, hast du damals Rui Pinto als Hacker bezeichnet und ich habe in dem Zusammenhang eben gesagt, dass man da vorsichtig sein muss, jemanden als solchen zu bezeichnen, wenn es dafür eben keine Belege gibt. Im Übrigen bis heute keine Belege gibt. Dass einen Namen klar zu nennen, eine Bezugsgröße herzustellen zu einer Person, zu einer Örtlichkeit, ohne dass es dafür eine Beleglage gibt, davor habe ich gewarnt. Das war im Moment der Oktober 2018, als das Sabado-Artikel kam. Damals gab es weder einen internationalen Haftbefehl, noch gab es weiterführende Erkenntnisse dazu, dass Rui Pinto tatsächlich die Person ist, die mit diesen Vorwürfen zu tun hat. Er selbst weiß ja bis heute beispielsweise den Punkt von sich, dass er irgendetwas mit dieser Benfica-Geschichte zu tun hat. Also den Datenmengen rund um Benfica-Lisabon. Man kann das glauben oder man kann es sein lassen. Das ist unabhängig davon. Ich habe ja eigentlich nur auf die Fairness versucht hinzuweisen oder die journalistische Sorgfaltspflicht hinzuweisen, dass wir dann eben sowohl das Dementi darstellen müssen, solange es noch keine Verurteilung oder solange es keine rechtskräftigen Beweise dazu gibt oder zumindest in der Verdachtsberichterstattung nicht so starke Punkte gibt, die diese Vorwürfe erhärten, als auch eben die Tatsache, dass man dort ja auch einen jungen Menschen dann schützen muss, wenn sich am Ende diese Sachen als unwahr herausstellen. Das war der Oktober 2018.
Wobei du natürlich der Einzige warst, der wusste, wie die Wahrheit ist. Aber okay, ich will das jetzt auch nicht überstrapazieren.
Aber auch da muss ich reinkriegeln. Ich weiß nicht, was die Wahrheit ist.
Du wusstest, dass es stimmt, dass er der Mann ist, der hinter Football Leaks steht. Ob als Einziger oder als Teil einer Gruppe. Diskutabel, in welcher Rolle auch diskutabel. Aber du wusstest, dass das, was Sabado damals herausgefunden hatte, nämlich dass Rui Pinto derjenige ist, der die Daten veröffentlicht und der auch in Kontakt mit dir steht. Das war ja richtig.
Genau, aber auch da habe ich dir gesagt, das war ja zu dem Zeitpunkt nichts Neues. Das gab es ja schon seit 2016. Es gab ja mal diesen anonymen Blog-Eintrag, das Ding hieß Football Leaks Revealed auf WordPress. Auch dort wurde damals Rui Pinto als Person gezeigt. Sein Gesicht wurde gezeigt, seine Örtlichkeit wurde benannt. Und trotzdem ist es am Ende nichts von den Vorwürfen, die 2016 gegen ihn öffentlich wurden, am Ende irgendwie in der Realität von einer Ermittlungsbehörde umgesetzt worden. Von daher streitet er das bis heute alles ab. Im Oktober 2018 gab es noch keinen Haftbefehl. Also weiß ich bis heute nicht, ob das, was er geschrieben hat, stimmt oder nicht. Was ich 2018 wusste, ist, dass es Rui Pinto gibt und dass er mit Football Leaks zu tun hat.
Du hast ja viel beschrieben, wie du dich mit John oder Rui Pinto getroffen hast. Viele Details sind da auch gefallen. Unter anderem geht es oft um den Ort. Man weiß jetzt, er hat in Budapest gelebt. Du bist auch häufig in eine osteuropäische Metropole geflogen. Du hast aber später auch mal geschrieben, dass du euch auch manchmal in kleinen Dörfern getroffen habt. Er ist ja auch einmal nach Hamburg gekommen, zum Spiegel selbst. Hast du denn zum Schutz Rui Pintos Dinge da ausgeschmückt, hinzugedichtet? Oder ist das alles, was in den Büchern steht, so für bare Münze zu nehmen, was jetzt quasi den Umgang mit Rui Pinto angeht?
Also ich habe eher Sachen weggelassen als hinzugenommen. Hinzugenommen habe ich nichts. Also nichts zumindest, was mir irgendwie einfallen würde. So etwas mache ich nicht, dass ich eine falsche Spur lege, um eine Quelle zu schützen. Aber ich lasse Dinge weg. Dinge, die möglicherweise auf den Ort hinweisen würden oder auf ihn als Person hinweisen würden. Die habe ich manchmal aus logischen, nachvollziehbaren Gründen die Städte anonymisiert oder habe die Wege dahin anonymisiert.
Aber ihr habt euch auch in anderen Städten als Budapest getroffen.
Ja, absolut. In vielen anderen Städten.
Und dann gibt es so eine Sache, die macht einen fast ein bisschen fassungslos und die hat auch dich fassungslos gemacht, nach dem, wie du schreibst. Und zwar haben wir auf der einen Seite auf damals noch John angesetzte Privatdetektive und auch eine Angst seinerseits, dass er aufgedeckt werden würde. Auf der anderen Seite lebt er unter seinem normalen Namen in Budapest und hat sogar einen Facebook-Account. Das hat auch dich einigermaßen sprachlos zurückgelassen. Wie passt denn das jetzt im Nachhinein für dich zusammen? Ich kriege das ehrlich gesagt nicht übereinander.
Jetzt würde ich den ganz plumpen Spruch benutzen, weil so ist einfach manchmal Journalismus. Ich kriege bei Football Leaks ganz vieles nicht zueinander. Aber das ist eben auch das Spannende an diesem Projekt, dass es eben nicht schwarz und weiß ist, sondern ganz vieles dieses Projekts im Graubereich ist, so wie Menschen eben auch sind. Solche Brüche gibt es sowohl in Persönlichkeiten von Menschen, als auch in Lebenswegen von Menschen. Dass Pinto eine gemeldete Adresse bzw. einen Mietvertrag hatte, dass er sich dort als Person in Budapest sehr auffindbar war, das ist für mich etwas, was ich in der Tat bis zum Gerichtsverfahren mir nicht vorstellen konnte. Ich war dann irgendwann total fassungslos, als der Rechtsanwalt mich informierte, dass es einen rechtsgültigen Mietvertrag gibt. Weil mit einem Mietvertrag, in meinem Verständnis, müsste es für Behörden eigentlich möglich sein, jemanden relativ zeitnah zu finden. Ich verstehe nicht wirklich, warum das nicht passiert ist. Auch das ist ja eine Frage, die offen bleibt. Da wird in Portugal über Jahre, wie auch immer, geartet, ermittelt. Da gibt es zahlreiche Versuche, bei Europol ein Haftbefehl zu erwirken. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es eine Person, die einen Mietbetrag hat, die einen Facebook-Account hat, die ein Gesicht bei Facebook hat, die aber gleichzeitig auf tausend andere Sachen wie verrückt achtet. Er hat sich mit seinem Smartphone auch selten aus dem Haus bewegt, bzw. hat auf seinem Smartphone auch Apps gehabt, die GPS-Signale verändert haben, die keine GPS-Zuordnung ermöglicht haben. Also hat da sehr darauf geachtet, dass seine Animität gewahrt wird. Naja, und hat gleichzeitig einen Facebook-Account. Ich habe ihn das irgendwann mal gefragt. Er hat mir auch ein Argument genannt, was ich halbwegs nachvollziehen konnte, warum er den hat. Dieses Argument kann ich aber jetzt nicht nennen, weil ich nicht weiß, ob er das möchte, dass ich das sage. Deswegen habe ich es auch im Buch nicht geschrieben. Aber das sind so Dinge, die ich auch nicht zusammenbekomme. Man muss natürlich dazu sagen, der Typ ist 30 Jahre alt. Das ist jetzt kein Profi aus einem Geheimdienst oder so, der mit tausend sehr klaren Bewegungsschemater sich durch die Welt bewegt hat. Das habe ich ihm bis zum Schluss auch abgekauft, angetrieben von dem Wunsch, dieses Fußballbusiness transparenter zu machen und zu zeigen, dass es in diesem Fußballbusiness zu echten Verfehlungen in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten gekommen ist. Und der möglicherweise einfach von seinem eigenen Projektgedanken viel zu sehr getrieben war, auch bis zum Schluss getrieben war. Irgendwann fängt man dann wohl auch an, das Risiko nicht so zu betrachten, wie man es hätte tun müssen. Insbesondere dann, wenn man vielleicht dann auch sich so ein bisschen in diesem Projekt verliert. Vielleicht ist das auch ein Punkt.
Er hat definitiv auch Fehler begangen, die jetzt auch zu ihm geführt haben, die man nicht so erwartet hätte von jemanden, der offenbar versiert im Umgang mit Computern zu sein scheint. Also über dieselbe E-Mail-Adresse zum Beispiel, das russische E-Mail-Konto von Artem Labatsurov angelegt. Das ist derjenige, die gefakete Identität, mit der ein Erpressungsversuch vonstatten ging, über den wir auch gleich noch sprechen müssen. Und mit derselben IP-Adresse, die zwar verschlüsselt war, aber es war eben die gleiche dann auch den Football Leaks E-Mail-Account bei diesem russischen Mail-Anbieter. Und da gibt es noch viele andere Dinge, da muss man dann tatsächlich ein bisschen graben, um die auch zu finden in Medien. Es wird wie immer ausreichend Links geben in den Show Notes dazu. Die Grundlage quasi der Fragen, die ich jetzt hier stelle. Bevor wir aber jetzt mal zu dem kommen, was da mit ihm passiert ist, rund um Auslieferungen an Portugal und Anklage dort. Deine Einschätzung, ist denn das Projekt Football Leaks jetzt vorbei?
Nein, vorbei ist es nicht, weil wir immer noch auf diesem riesigen Datenberg hier sitzen. Und weil ich auch nicht weiß, ob es am Ende nicht doch noch deutlich mehr Personen gibt als Rui Pinto. Das ist ja auch eine der großen Fragen. Er selbst sagt, er hat dieses Projekt nie alleine geführt. Wir haben auch einen Hinweis darauf, dass das möglicherweise stimmen kann, weil als er verhaftet wurde, ist uns nochmal ein weiterer Football Leaks Datensatz bzw. ein Dokument. Es war kein großer Datensatz, sondern mehrere Dokumente, die uns nochmal zugeschickt wurden.
Auf welchem Weg?
Das möchte ich zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt zumindest noch nicht sagen, aber zumindest einen Weg, der auf jemanden hinweisen muss, der mit Football Leaks zu tun hat. Ich weiß nicht, wie er das gemacht haben könnte, gemacht haben sollte. Vielleicht hat er es irgendwie gemacht. Ich kann nicht schlecht beantworten. Aber das ist zumindest das, was Rui Pinto immer gesagt hat, dass er Football Leaks nicht alleine gemacht hat. Als ich ihn gefragt habe, wie ich mit seinen möglichen Mitstreitern irgendwann mal in Kontakt treten könnte, hat er mir damals gesagt, dass sie mit mir in Kontakt treten werden, wenn es so weit ist. Schauen wir mal, ob da noch was kommt oder nicht kommt. Aber was zumindest in den nächsten Monaten mit Football Leaks sicherlich zu tun haben wird und auch dort eine große Rolle spielen wird, ist der Prozess zum Rui Pinto. Wenn der Richter die Anklage der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft annimmt, dann wird es sicherlich relativ zeitnah zu einem Prozess kommen, in dem es noch einmal um die Aufarbeitung der letzten Jahre gehen wird. Davon ist jetzt auch noch mal abhängig, welche Vorwürfe tatsächlich zugelassen werden. Wenn man sich die Verhaftung und den Haftbefehl anschaut, ist das schon auf europäischer Ebene eine ziemlich skurrile. Und auch, um ehrlich zu sein, mal gucken, ob wirklich rechtstaatliche Vorgehensweise, die dort stattfindet. Der Haftbefehl selbst, mit dem Rui Pinto verhaftet wurde im Januar, beinhaltet ja nur Vorwürfe aus dem Jahr 2015. Also nur, in Anführungsstrichen. Dort geht es um vier oder fünf Fälle der möglichen Cyberkriminalität und um den Vorwurf der versuchten Erpressung. Bei dem Vorwurf der versuchten Erpressung muss man dazu sagen, dass zu keinem Zeitpunkt Geld geflossen ist. Pinto hat kein Geld erhalten. Warum auch immer nicht erhalten. Dementsprechend ist eigentlich dieser Vorgang – Pinto selbst bestreitet, dass er jemanden erpressen wollte. Die Firma Doyon Sports sagt, er wollte erpressen. Mal sehen, wie die ermittelnden Behörden das sehen. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es noch den Verein Sporting Lisbon, der Pinto den Vorwurf gemacht hat, dass Pinto Zugriff auf die Mailkonten bzw. offenbar auf die Daten von Sporting Lisbon hatte. Aber das sind die einzigen Vorwürfe aus dem Jahr 2015. Damit ist Pinto nach Portugal ausgeliefert worden. Im Zuge der Ermittlungen in Portugal sind dann offenbar noch weitere Fälle auf seinem Rechner gefunden worden, die aber eigentlich nach den rechtsstaatlichen Vorgängen in Europa nicht gefunden werden dürfen. Normalerweise darf sich die ermittelnde Staatsanwaltschaft bzw. die Polizei nur mit den Vorwürfen beschäftigen, die in dem Haftbefehl enthalten sind. Die Portugiesen haben dann im Zuge dieses Haftbefehls irgendwann mal um die Erweiterung des Haftbefehls in Ungarn gebeten, um möglicherweise weitere Straftaten aufzuklären. Sie sind dort im Prinzip in diese Grundthese reingelaufen, die es schon bei der Verhaftung gab, dass sie diesen Haftbefehl von 2015 nur aktiviert haben, um Zugriff auf möglicherweise weitere Straftaten von Pinto zu erhalten. Das wird man jetzt sehen, ob es wirklich Straftaten sind. Ich bin vor allem auch auf die Beweisführung sehr gespannt. Das ist ja das eine, Daten auf dem eigenen Rechner zu haben bzw. Daten dort vorliegen zu haben. Das andere ist die Beweisführung, wie diese Daten auf diesen Rechner gelangt sind. Dazu habe ich auch in der Anklage bislang noch wenig gesehen. In der Anklage gibt es zahlreiche Städte, aus denen offenbar ein Angriff auf bestimmte Datenbanken, Vereine, Kanzleien wie auch immer stattgefunden hat. Aber das waren Städte wie São Paulo, wie St. Petersburg, wie Hongkong, also alles Mögliche. Das kann auf der einen Seite passiert sein, wenn jemand mit VPN ins Internet geht und über einen Torbrowser seine eigene IP-Adresse verschlüsselt. Das ist die eine Theorie, die von der Staatsanwaltschaft kommt. Es gibt aber auch schlicht und ergreifend die andere Möglichkeit, dass es eben verschiedene Menschen sind. Das alles muss der Prozess zeigen. Deshalb glaube ich, dass rund um den Prozess das Ganze auch noch ziemlich spannend wird.
Jetzt sieht aber allein die Anklage sehr monströs aus. Anklagen sehen immer schlecht aus für den Beklagten. Das ist der Sinn einer Anklage. Aber wenn ich lese, dass Rui Pinto vorgeworfen wird, 147 Verbrechen begangen zu haben. Die Anklageschrift hat 195 Seiten. Ich gebe zu, ich habe sie nicht gelesen. Deswegen kann ich jetzt auch nicht da kontern, wenn du sagst, die Beweisführung ist dünn zu beweisen, dass es tatsächlich Rui Pinto war. Dann sieht es aber schon nach sehr deutlichen Vorwürfen aus. Gleichzeitig war ja diese Frage, wie kommt John, respektive Rui Pinto, an die Daten, das hing von Tag 1 über Football Leaks? Das habt ihr auch thematisiert. Das haben wir auch hier im Rasenfunk schon häufig besprochen. Das war aber vor allem für andere Medien, nach dem, was wir ja auch diskutiert haben und was man auch so lesen konnte, mit einer der Hauptgründe, Kritik an dem Projekt zu üben. Auch in Football Leaks 2 diskutiert ihr im Jahr 2018 nochmal darüber, wie ihr mit diesen Vorwürfen gegenüber Rui Pinto umgehen sollt. Findest du, ihr habt das ausreichend gekennzeichnet, dass die Herkunft dieser Daten sehr unsicher ist und aus einer illegalen Machenschaft kommen könnte?
Also ich glaube, mehr als das, was wir dazu gemacht haben, kannst du doch gar nicht mehr machen. Also wir haben das in jedem Artikel, also in jedem größeren Artikel, bei dem wir auch auf die Quelle hingewiesen haben, haben wir uns mit den Vorwürfen rund um Rui Pinto beschäftigt, zuletzt im November 2018 in dem Super League Artikel, in dem wir ein ganzes Bein drin haben, bei dem wir uns nur mit Rui Pinto beschäftigen und auch mit den damaligen Vorwürfen, die auch Salvador erhoben hat und die aus Portugal kamen. Wir haben im Dezember 2016 mit der ersten Football Leaks-Welle den kompletten Erpressungsversuch, wenn man ihn so nennen möchte, des Artem Lubosov, von dem wir jetzt wissen, dass es Rui Pinto ist, damals es aber noch nicht wussten, beschrieben und auch damals schon darauf hingewiesen, dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, dass das jemand von Football Leaks ist, egal wer. Auch da bewegen wir uns ja in der Verdachtsberichterstattung und dem presserechtlichen Bereich. Wir können ja schlecht zu dem Zeitpunkt sagen, das ist John. So können wir nicht, weil er selbst bestreitet das, er selbst sagt, oder er hat es nicht bestritten, sondern er hat sich dazu nicht eingelassen. Das heißt, im Zuge der Verdachtsberichterstattung können wir aufweisen, es gibt diese E-Mail-Adresse, die auch von Yandex kommt, die auch mit Football Leaks zu tun hat, die möglicherweise eben auch eine Person von Football Leaks ist. Wir haben nur Kontakt zu einer Person, die befragen wir, die konfrontieren wir sauber mit den Vorwürfen und hören dann dazu, dass sie sagt, sie möchte, das sei lächerlich und sie möchte nicht zu allen Bezug nehmen, was irgendwie in den Medien ihr vorgehalten wird. Das stellen wir dann also entsprechend da und das war unsere Haltung, die wir bis heute verfolgt haben. Ehrlicherweise weiß ich gar nicht, ob im Nachgang, ob das alles so richtig ist, so viel Transparenz in einem solchen Projekt walten zu lassen. Vielleicht wäre es sogar besser gewesen, überhaupt nicht über die Vorwürfe zu sprechen. Ich spinne jetzt gerade rum, ich würde es beim nächsten Mal wieder so machen, aber ich wollte auf einen anderen Punkt hinaus.
Ja, auf den bin ich gespannt.
Ja, wenn du dir anguckst, wie die Offshore Leaks, wie die Paradise Papers, wie die Panama Papers, wie die Bahama Leaks abgelaufen sind. Das sind alles sehr große, gesellschaftlich extrem wichtige Enthüllungen, die etwas verändert haben, die sowohl etwas im steuerrechtlichen Sinne verändert haben, als auch eben gezeigt haben, wie immens anfällig Europa in der Steuerpolitik ist. Und trotzdem schwebt ja auch über diesen großen Enthüllungen durchweg der Vorwurf, dass diese Kanzleien von außen gehackt wurden. Also sowohl Mossack von Seckar als auch Appleby haben beide gesagt, sie seien gehackt worden. Da ist vielleicht dann, keine Ahnung, die Kollegen von ISZ haben einen etwas anderen Weg als wir gewählt, auch weil sie eben keinen, zumindest sagen sie, dass sie keinen direkten Kontakt zu ihrer Quelle gehabt haben und dementsprechend den Weg etwas anders gewählt haben. Wir haben hier von vornherein gesagt, dadurch, dass wir mit Pinto zu tun haben, müssen wir bestimmte Leitplanken für uns feststellen, um zu erklären, bis wohin kann man schützen und ab wo muss man als Journalist dann sagen, das Projekt ist zu Ende oder möglicherweise können wir mit diesem Projekt nicht weiter umgehen. Wir haben für uns ja dann auch irgendwann mal definiert, was sind eigentlich die Vorwürfe gegen ihn und wie hoch ist die gesellschaftliche Relevanz dessen, was er enthüllt hat oder was er dargestellt hat. Das führt dann unweigerlich auch zu den ganz großen Fragen der Digitalisierung und der Frage, wer eigentlich ein Whistleblower ist. Wer darf als Whistleblower bezeichnet werden? Wir haben den alten Begriff des Whistleblowers, also jemand, der aus einem Unternehmen kommt und in einem Unternehmen Dokumente gefunden hat, die er dann der Öffentlichkeit aufzeigen muss. Aber ist das wirklich die letztgültige Beschreibung eines Whistleblowers oder kann ein Whistleblower auch möglicherweise von außen kommen und Dokumente erhalten, die einen so hohen gesellschaftlichen Wert haben, dass man sie der Öffentlichkeit zukommen lassen muss und trotzdem für sich in Anspruch nehmen kann, dass man den Schutz des Whistleblowers genießt? Für uns ist es definitorisch so, dass Rui Pinto ein erhebliches Maß an persönlichen Risiken auf sich genommen hat, um der Welt zu zeigen, wie problematisch diese Fußballbranche tatsächlich ist und wie durchzogen sie von fragwürdigen, kriminellen Finanzflüssen und Machenschaften ist. Dementsprechend trifft für uns die Bezeichnung, dass Rui Pinto ein Whistleblower ist ziemlich genau zu. Es gibt einen Parallelfall, der ein bisschen drauf angelegt werden kann. Das ist Antoine Deltour, der die Lachsleaks damals an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht hat. Deltour ist bei einem regionalen Gericht als Krimineller verurteilt worden, weil er Daten aus einem Computer eines Unternehmens entwendet hat. Er ist dann aber von dem Europäischen Gerichtshof als Whistleblower klassifiziert worden.
Als erster seiner Art in der Form. Aber jenseits von diesen Interpretationsfragen, die uns sicherlich in der Zukunft noch weiter beschäftigen werden – das ist auch eine Diskussion, die wichtig ist, geführt zu werden. Auch der staatliche Umgang mit Whistleblowern im Unterschied zum Beispiel von Frankreich zu Deutschland und so weiter. Das sind Diskussionen, die sollen geführt werden und die sollen auch nicht nur anhand von Rui Pinto geführt werden. Aber wenn wir uns jetzt allein mal den Datensatz angucken, den ihr habt, oder die Datensätze, die ihr bekommen habt, gibt es denn auch, wenn da persönliche Nachrichten zum Beispiel mit dabei sind? Da erinnere ich mich, dass im Football Leaks 1 zum Beispiel aus direkten Chats von zwei Personen zitiert wurden. Kann es denn dafür überhaupt einen legalen Weg gegeben haben, diese Daten zusammen? Spricht nicht alles dafür?
Naja, die Frage ist, inwiefern wir das bewerten sollten. Was bedeutet eine illegale Datenbeschaffung oder nicht? Für uns als Journalisten ist das Presserecht maßgeblich. Und das Presserecht sagt, dass wir auch mit mutmaßlich illegal erworbenen Daten arbeiten können, solange wir eine Person nicht dazu anstiften oder dazu anleiten.
Und das habt ihr auch nicht getan.
Also es ist zu keinem Zeitpunkt. Die Trennlinie zwischen Rui Pinto und mir, was das angeht, war brutal und ist auch bis heute. Ich benutze immer diesen Satz, dass ich sage, dann hätte ich ihn sicherlich irgendwann mal gefragt, ob er mir was zu Uli Hoeneß.
Oder sonst was besorgen kann. In Football Leaks 1, noch bevor ihr euch zum ersten Mal trefft, schreibt ihr zum Beispiel, ich habe ein kleines Geschenk für dich und dann geht es um deutsche Spieler in Dokumenten, die angehängt sind. Es fällt ja auch auf, dass sich der Fokus der Leaks von Portugal über Spanien zur Premier League und immer mehr auch in einen Bereich, der dann auf einmal auch den DFB beeinflusst, der die DFL beeinflusst und eben deutsche Vereine trifft. Also von außen betrachtet sieht das schon so aus, als hätte es da eine Interessenserweiterung gegeben, von seiner Seite zumindest.
Den DFB und die DFL?
Naja, wenn wir über Super League sprechen, dann sind wir ja in der DFL respektive und in der DFB-Geschichte rund um die Uhren, das war doch auch aus Football Leaks Beständen oder nicht?
Okay, gut, dann streichen wir den DFB – Ja, auch die DFL kannst du streichen, weil die Sachen, die wir zu Super League hatten, hatten keinen, also kamen...
Nur von den Vereinen?
Ja, also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es dort irgendeinen Link zu einer deutschen Gruppierung gab. Diese Sachen können auf, oder ich vermute zumindest grob, dass diese Sachen einen anderen Ursprung hatten. Ich kann es aber nicht nachhalten oder belegen, aber du kannst ja sehen, wie viele Mannschaften involviert waren, in die Gespräche der Super League. Also da ist keineswegs eine Zuordnung auf eine Örtlichkeit oder einen Verein oder eine Person gegeben. Nein, aber um das nochmal sehr, sehr klar zu sagen, ich habe mit Rui Pinto zu keinem Zeitpunkt über irgendwelche Themen geredet oder ihn gebeten, irgendwelche Themen für uns zu suchen oder zu finden. Das wäre strafrechtlich Wahnsinn. Und so sehr ich meinen Job liebe, gibt es bestimmte Grenzen, die ich ganz sicher für diesen Job nicht aufs Spiel setzen würde. Und das ist so eine, die ich zu keinem Zeitpunkt übertreten habe.
Er soll sich jetzt eben in Portugal vor allem für das Hacken in Portugal verantworten. Er soll unter anderem laut Anklageschrift Sporting Lissabon, dem Portugiesischen Fußballverband, zwei Anwaltskanzleien, den Südamerikanischen Fußballverband, die FIFA, die UEFA und sogar das Büro des Staatsanwalts gehackt haben. Das wird ihm vorgeworfen. Wirst du denn in Portugal auch vor Ort sein, um über diesen Prozess zu berichten? Oder hältst du dich daraus jetzt raus? Denn es könnte ja sein, dass du Teil dieses Prozesses bist. Du bist der Einzige, über den Rui Pinto seine Daten in die Öffentlichkeit bringen konnte.
Wie gesagt, bislang habe ich keinerlei Hinweise darauf, dass ich in irgendeiner Form Teil eines Ermittlungsverfahrens bin oder dass gegen mich oder gegen uns als Medienunternehmen ermittelt wird.
Du wurdest auch noch nicht angefragt von den portugiesischen Behörden?
Ich wurde weder angefragt noch befragt, noch in irgendeiner Form informiert. Ganz im Gegenteil, ich habe, wie gesagt, die portugiesische Justiz zigmal, um Erlaubnis gebeten, mit Pinto vor Ort sprechen zu dürfen, in Interviewen zu dürfen, ihn auch zu den Vorwürfen befragen zu dürfen. Das heißt, im Umkehrschluss, wenn die portugiesische Justiz mich hätte sehen wollen, wäre es relativ einfach, mir einfach die Erlaubnis zu geben, mit Pinto zu reden, dann wäre ich nämlich im Land gewesen. Das haben sie aber strikt abgelehnt im letzten halben Jahr. Mein Plan ist es, den Prozess sehr eng zu begleiten. Das ist eine der zentralen Aufgaben, die ich jetzt hier eigentlich auch für die nächsten Monate für mich sehe, die mich auch auslasten wird, wenn es dann dazu kommt. Ich vergleiche das immer so ein bisschen mit dem Prozess rund um Ante Shapina und rund um die Matchfixer in Bochum aus dem Jahr 2010, 2011. Ich vergleiche es nicht von der Kriminalität, sondern von der reinen Masse. Damals war es auch so, dass über 300 Spiele manipuliert gewesen sein sollen, dass sich Verdachtsfälle der Manipulation auch in der Anklageschrift aufgetaucht sind. Wenn man sich am Ende anguckt, was für ein Promillesatz Shapina und Co. verurteilt wurden, also wie wenig Spiele am Ende hängen geblieben sind und wie lange der Prozess dann auch andauerte inklusive aller Revisionen und Revisionsverfahren. Da bin ich gespannt, was von dieser schieren Masse, die sich am Anfang wiegt, wie so eine 147 bzw. so 152 mutmaßliche Straftaten, die in der Anklage aufgeführt sind. Wenn man sich das anguckt, ist das schon gewaltig. Man kommt dann nach dem ersten Lesen aber auch relativ schnell zu dem Punkt, dass dort beispielsweise die Straftat Cyberkriminalität im Umkehrschluss fast zweimal gewertet wird, weil du auf der einen Seite Cyberkriminalität hast und auf der anderen Seite den Straftatbestand des Briefgeheimnisses, also des Bruchs des Briefgeheimnisses, die sich aufdröseln, aber dort die gleiche Wertigkeit haben. Ich glaube, der Hauptangriffspunkt ist nach wie vor die versuchte Erpressung. Wenn die versuchte Erpressung so nicht gehalten werden kann, dann bin ich gespannt, wie es sich mit den anderen Vorwürfen verhält. Weil bei den anderen Vorwürfen brauchst du eigentlich eine Belegkette oder eine Indizienkette. Das heißt, du musst nachweisen können, welches WLAN benutzt wurde, du musst nachweisen können, welcher Computer benutzt wurde, du musst nachweisen können, von wo nach wo der Einbruch stattgefunden hat. Also jetzt aus der Reihenlogik all der anderen Hacking-Fälle, die wir in den letzten Jahren irgendwie hier gesehen haben, ohne zu sagen, dass Rui Pinto ebenfalls gehackt hat. Aber aus all den Fällen war schon sehr ersichtlich, dass Cyberkriminalität in der Aufklärung keineswegs so einfach ist. Und ich persönlich die ganze Zeit auch da, der der Fragefolge, warum sich die Justiz komplett dermaßen fokussiert auf die Aufklärung dieser Straftaten und auf keinen der Anfragen auch der anderen Justizbehörden Europas eingeht, die ja mit dem Material arbeiten wollen, weil sie feststellen, dass es in Europa zahlreich andere Bereiche gibt, die mit dem Material ernsthafte, große Straftaten aufklären können und eine Unterstützung der Aufklärung dieser Straftaten dort stattfinden könnte, ohne verharmlosen zu wollen – man sollte so früh am Morgen nicht so viele Fremdwörter nutzen – ohne verharmlosen zu wollen, dass die Vorwürfe gegen Rui Pinto schon absolut ausreichen, um ein Verfahren anzustreben, wenn sie sich so bewahrheitet.
Wenn sie sich so bewahrheitet, ja, aber die Vorwürfe sind durchaus schwer wegen. Das bringt uns ja aber auch zur Rolle des Spiegels als Institution generell im Umgang mit der Darstellung, wie zum Beispiel dieser Prozess abläuft. Da ist mir zum Beispiel ein kleines Detail aufgefallen, an dem wir vielleicht ganz gut euren, nicht Interessenskonflikt, aber den schmalen Grad beschreiben können, den da der Spiegel auch in seiner Darstellung gehen muss. Und zwar beziehe ich mich auf die Darstellung des Anwalts von Rui Pinto, das ist William Bourdon. Das ist der Anwalt unter anderem von bekannten Whistleblauern, aber auch von Michel Platini, der rund um die WM-Vergabe 2022 in Korruptionsverwürfe verstrickt ist und ebenfalls von Lamine Diac, Ex-Präsident des Leichtathletik-Weltverbandes, der wegen Korruption von den französischen Behörden angeklagt wurde. Den Hinweis auf die anderen Whistleblower im Portfolio von Bourdon, den finde ich. Den Hinweis auf Platini und Lamine Diac, finde ich in den Büchern nicht.
Weil jeder Punkt hätten wir wahrscheinlich mit aufführen müssen, ich muss dazu sagen, dass ich bislang mit Bourdon über diese Fälle, also sehr bewusst auch nicht gesprochen habe, weil ich genau in diesen Interessenkonflikt nicht kommen wollte. Ich wollte von ihm weder wissen, wie seine Vertretung von Diac, noch wie seine Vertretung von Platini abläuft schlicht und ergreifend, weil ich, wie er selbst darüber schreiben und diesen Anwalt, der dann noch so ein bisschen zwischen den Stühlen möglicherweise sitzt, in dem Fall gar nicht damit, also mit meiner eigenen Rolle gar nicht behelligen möchte. Weil meine eigene Rolle da ja auch schon so ist, dass ich natürlich sehr viel auch über Pinto weiß und mit ihm zu tun hatte und da für mich eben eine Grenze gesetzt habe.
Aber wäre das für die Leser nicht wichtig zu wissen?
Ja, deswegen habe ich gerade gesagt, möglicherweise ist das ein Punkt, über den wir hätten auch ausführlicher auch debattieren müssen, ob man Platini mit rein nimmt, also zumindest Platini mit rein nimmt. Die Jagd ist ja weit weg vom Fußball, obwohl ich jetzt gerade am Wochenende Abend im Spiegel eine Enthüllungsgeschichte über die beiden Diags gehabt, an der ich mitgearbeitet habe, bei der es mich manchmal in den Fingern gejuckt hat, Boudin anzurufen. Aber mit Fußball hat die Jagd nicht zu tun. Trotzdem, bei Platini hätte dieser Hinweis möglicherweise mit rein gesollt. Ich weiß persönlich aber nicht, wie das Mandatsverhältnis zwischen Boudin und Platini ist. Ich kenne dort die Hintergründe nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob er ihn ausschließlich in dem FIFA-Fall vertritt oder ob er ihn grundsätzlich vertritt. Das ist etwas, womit ich mich einfach zu wenig beschäftigt habe, weil auch Platini für uns ja nicht die allergrößte Rolle in den Football Leaks gespielt hat. Und trotzdem ist es ein Punkt, das sollten wir in Zukunft aufnehmen, dass wir Platini da möglicherweise mit reinschreiben. Aber manchmal ist es auch eine Darstellungssache. Für die Erklärung, dass Platini auch mit von Boudin vertreten wird, müsste man sofort auch einen relativ großen Erkläransatz wählen, um in dem Zuge zu erläutern, was Platini eigentlich vorgeworfen wird und was er…
Ist jetzt eine stilistische Frage, aber ist auf jeden Fall eine weiterführende Information.
Ich weiß, dass wir damals darüber diskutiert haben, aber alle, die auch der Meinung waren, dass Platini eine so untergeordnete Rolle in den Football Leaks gespielt hat, dass er eigentlich dort keine Rolle spielt und dass es bei Boudoir auch eine sehr klare Chinese Wall gibt. Er hat das damals auch Pinto früh gesagt, dass er gesagt hat, er hat dieses Mandat und dass er die beiden Mandatseiten nicht mehr miteinander in Berührung bringen möchte. In Wahrheit haben das zahlreiche Anwälte und oft genug schreiben wir genau über diese Interessenkonflikte. Von daher werden wir über den Punkt noch einmal nachdenken, dass es ein valider Punkt ist.
Ist denn mal Geld vom Spiegel zu Rui Pinto geflossen? Für die Daten, für Reisen, für Essen?
Ich habe das ja schon zigmal gesagt, dass wir weder für die Daten noch für die Dokumente in irgendeiner Form Geld bezahlt haben. Wenn es Auslagen oder sonstiges gab, dann haben sie sich komplett im Rahmen der Richtlinien dieses Hauses hier bewegt und das machen wir ja nicht nur mit Rui Pinto, sondern das machen wir dann auch mit dem einen oder anderen geschätzten Informanten, den wir…
Kannst du mir den Rahmen dieser Richtlinien nennen, weil ich kenne ihn nicht? Also, dass man dann nur für Reisen und Spesen zahlt oder was ist der Rahmen?
Genau, also ich bin ein großer Freund davon bei Spesen zu sagen, dass das etwas ist, was zwischen dem Medium und zwischen der Quelle behandelt wird und die Öffentlichkeit in dem Rahmen eigentlich auch im höchsten Transparenzsinn nicht zu bewegen hat, weil das Ausgaben sind, die sich in einem solchen kleinen Rahmen bzw. so geringen Rahmen bewegen, dass sie keinerlei größere oder nennenswerte Faktoren für einen Zusammenhang zwischen Journalisten und zwischen Quellen spielen können. Also nein, ich werde über diese Dinge nicht sprechen, weil ich auch nicht weiß, ob mein Unternehmen möchte, dass ich über Spesenrichtlinien spreche. Es ist etwas, was die Unternehmen dann ja auch für sich selbst definieren. Aber wie gesagt, es sind Kleckerbeträge.
Okay. Ich stelle die Frage deshalb. Ich würde mich ja auch nicht an so Kleinigkeiten aufhängen, wenn ich nicht einen größeren Kontext dazu hätte, der die Frage rechtfertigt. Und ich stelle die Frage deshalb, weil wir bei Rui Pinto einen Hacker, Whistleblower, Informanten, was auch immer haben, der eben nicht in einem fest angestellten Verhältnis zu einem Unternehmen ist, sondern der irgendwie seinen Lebensunterhalt in Budapest finanzieren muss. Glaubst du, dass John tatsächlich nur über das An- und Verkaufen von antiquarischen Dingen getan hat, so wie er es dir gesagt hat?
Ich bin ein Faktenmensch. Wir sind bei Glauben geraten werden. Schwierige Punkte. Ich glaube grundsätzlich vieles nicht. Vieles, was mir Informanten erzählen, vieles, was ich lese, glaube ich zunächst einmal nicht. Und dann versuche ich, mich an Inhalten abzuarbeiten. Und ich kann nur sagen, ich kenne die Lebensräumlichkeiten von Rui Pinto. Oder ich kannte sie. Ich weiß, wie seine Lebensführung ausgesehen hat. Und nichts von dem, was ich dort in den letzten dreieinhalb Jahren gesehen habe, hat darauf hingedeutet, dass das ein wohlhabender Mensch ist. Genau das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Der hat in echten Bruchbuden gehaust und gelebt. Der hat, ich glaube, dass ich ihn in dreieinhalb Jahren in zwei unterschiedlichen Jeans gesehen habe. Mit einem paar Schuhe im Winter und ein paar Schuhe im Sommer. Und jetzt möchte ich nicht, dass du mir als nächstes wieder sagst, dass das romanhaft ist, was ich sage, weil das ist die – so ist herumgelaufen. Der ist dreieinhalb Jahre mit einer Lederjacke durch die Gegend gerannt, egal ob es Winter oder Sommer war. Das teuerste, was er besessen hat, war sein Fernseher, den er sich irgendwann mal gekauft hat. Also für diesen Lebensstandard braucht man nicht so richtig viel.
Kann es möglich gewesen sein?
Ja, es kann aber auch möglich sein, dass er irgendwann mal geerbt hat. Es kann auch sein, dass er irgendwann mal Geld aus irgendeinem anderen Bereich erhalten hat. Die Grundannahmen, woher oder wie er seinen Lebensunterhalt am Ende finanziert hat, sind vielschichtig. Ich verweise auf das, was er selbst dazu sagt. Auch als er verhaftet wurde, hat die Polizei auf seinem Konto 4.500 Euro gefunden. Das war alles. Bislang habe ich auch nichts dazu gehört, dass sie irgendwelche Geldflüsse festgestellt hätten, die belastbar wären.
Gut, es gab natürlich auch mal Geldflüsse. Das liegt jetzt allerdings schon im Jahr 2013 zurück. Aber da waren auf seinem Konto erst 31, 67 Euro und dann irgendwann 227.000 Euro. Das war eben die Erleichterung der Caledonian Bank auf den Cayman Islands. Das ist aber eine Geschichte, die jetzt vor den Football Leaks stattgefunden hat.
Und man muss den Zusatz dazu sagen, die er zurück überwiesen hat.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber dennoch, wenn ich erst im Laden was klaue, wollen wir uns an der Sache jetzt nicht aufhängen.
Ich muss dazu noch einen Satz sagen, weil natürlich alle diese Dinge so in der Plastizität, wie du sie gerade darstellst, ein gewisses Licht entwickeln oder beziehungsweise jemanden auch in eine Verteidigungshaltung drängen bzw. in eine Erklärungshaltung auch ihn hinein drängen. Aber das sind doch auch nur die Fakten, wo du sagst, du bist…
Oder ist es jetzt ungerecht, dass ich das zitiere?
Nein, nein, nein, gar nicht. Ich will es nur erklären, weil zu den Fakten gehört natürlich auch noch eine zweite Seite. Wenn jemand tatsächlich in einer Bank einbricht und etwas geklaut haben soll und dass ein rein illegaler Vorgang wie auch immer geartet ist, dann bekommt man dafür in der Regel ja ein Strafverfahren. Man bekommt eine gerichtliche Auseinandersetzung und wird verknackt. All das ist im Fall von Rui Pinto nicht passiert. Es gab ein außergerichtliches Settlement zu dieser Geschichte, warum auch immer. Das sind halt einfach Punkte, bei denen ich dann auch an meine Erklärungsgrenzen stoße, wenn ich ihn dann gefragt habe, warum wurdest du nicht verhaftet? Ich meine, das ist ein Bank-Einbruch, wenn es denn so ist. Das ist ja etwas, was schwerwiegend ist und bei dem man dann auch im Zweifel ein paar Jahre einsetzt, gerade wenn es um eine sechsstellige Summe geht. Dann wollte er mir das oftmals nicht beantworten, sondern hat dann gesagt, ich habe eine Verschwiegenheitserklärung, ich kann dazu nicht sagen. Da kann man sich dann tausend Sachen drunter vorstellen und ausmalen, aber am Ende ist es eben dann doch nicht so einfach zu sagen, dass er eine rein kriminelle Handlung gemacht hat, weil möglicherweise gibt es dazu auch noch andere Erklärungen, möglicherweise gibt es dazu noch eine zweite Ebene, die ich bislang zumindest nicht verstanden habe. Ich möchte da zumindest noch den abschließenden Satz machen, dass die Football Leaks – das ist ja ein Projekt, bei dem du nicht nach einem Handbuch agierst. Das hätte ich mir oft gewünscht, dass wir in den letzten dreieinhalb Jahren dieses Projekt irgendwo ein Handbuch gehabt hätten des investigativen Leak-Journalismus, das uns klar definiert, was richtig, was falsch ist, ohne dass wir all unsere eigenen Fehler machen oder all unsere eigenen Erfahrungen machen und sie immer wieder neu justieren und darstellen, sei es jetzt von der Inhalts- oder von der Darstellungsseite oder vom Umgang mit einer Quelle. Das ist ja auch etwas, was man aus dem ganz normalen Alltag herausmacht, aus Erfahrungen, die in dem Moment ankommen, die man gemeinsam macht, aus Diskussionen, die man hier hat und aus – in Wahrheit – Try and Error. Auch das gehört dazu. Wir haben bestimmte rechtliche Vorgaben, an denen wir uns mit zig Anwälten orientiert haben. Dazu kommen die moralisch-ethischen Vorgaben, die dieses Haus für sich definiert. Und in diesem Rahmen haben wir versucht, uns zu bewegen. Ich finde es jetzt gut, dass wir uns einfach ein bisschen Zeit nehmen, um über solche plastischen Sachen zu sprechen, wie der ist doch ein Bankräuber. Das ist das Einfache, das mir mit der Aussage begegnet wird, der ist doch ein Bankräuber, das kann doch kein Whistleblower sein. So, und dann fängst du an, das Ganze aufzudröseln. Du fängst an, die nächste Metafrage zu stellen und die dritte Metafrage. Und dann sitzt du da oftmals irgendwann am Ende eines Abendessens und die Person, die einem gegenüber sitzt, sagt, ja, das sind schon irgendwie spannende Fragen, wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht, wie ich die beantworte. Und in dem Bereich bewegen wir uns ja hier jetzt gerade auch.
Ja, apropos spannende Fragen und die Frage, wie man sie beantwortet. Ihr habt dann nach der Enttarnung von John alias Rui Pinto, habt ihr auch in zwei Tagen, an zwei Tagen, ein Interview mit ihm geführt. Daraus entstammen auch all die Zitate, die im Intro zu hören waren. Das war dann auf dem YouTube-Kanal der Sportschau noch verfügbar. Warum habt ihr aus zwei Tagen Interview nicht viel mehr veröffentlicht? Ihr müsst doch stundenlang mit ihm gesprochen haben. Gab es mal die Überlegung zu sagen, wir stellen das aus Gründen der Transparenz, weil ihr müsst euch als Haus für euren Umgang mit den Football Leaks, gerade weil es ja eben dieses Handbuch dafür nicht gab, ja auch verantworten und selbst auch schützen? Gab es mal Überlegungen, davon mehr zu veröffentlichen? Ich war ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass es aus zwei Tagen nur so wenig rauskommt.
Also grundsätzlich ist ja die Aufgabe eines Journalisten, das Wesentliche darzustellen und nicht Unwesentlichen zu versinken. Wir hatten das Gefühl, dass wir aus dem Zusammenspiel der TV-Aufnahmen, der ARD bzw. des NDR und unserem eigenen gedruckten Interview, was damals, glaube ich, fünf oder sechs Seiten lang war, genug Informationsmaterial dem Leser geliefert haben, das noch im Rahmen des Konsumierbaren gewesen ist.
Na gut, du sprichst hier mit einem Podcast. Vielleicht habe ich da andere Maßstäbe. Aber verstehst du so ein bisschen, aus welcher Richtung meine Frage kommt? Ich hatte das Gefühl, das wäre jetzt mal ein Zeitpunkt gewesen, der erste öffentliche Eindruck von Rui Pinto und für jeden, den es interessiert. Also dass du jetzt nicht zwei Stunden Interview um 20.15 Uhr in der ARD sendest, das ist ja völlig klar, aber für jeden, den es interessiert, hätte man ja noch mehr verfügbar machen können zum Beispiel.
Ach ja, das sind ja dann auch alles Kapazitätsfragen. Also wir haben ja vorhin über die Länge des Buchs gesprochen. Es gibt Leute, die mich jetzt anschreiben und sagen, ihnen hätten 120 Seiten des Buchs gereicht. Andere melden sich und sagen, bitte mach sofort jetzt ein drittes Buch. Wir wollen weiterlesen. Das Ganze reicht noch nicht aus. Die Spannbreite aller Menschen wirst du mit Journalismus niemals bedienen können. Und zu sagen, dass man eine ungeschnittene Fassung eines Interviews mit einem Whistleblower online stellt als Submittel und sagt, hier kann jeder noch weiter sich das angucken, ist in der Tat vielleicht eine Überlegung, die man machen kann, wenn man hier mit einer 20-köpfigen Mannschaft oder sonst was dran sitzt, die das Ganze ja dann auch nochmal bearbeiten, aufarbeiten. Die Kapazitäten, also personelle Kapazitäten haben wir hier im Moment nicht. Wir haben damals, ich erinnere mich wirklich noch sehr, sehr lebhaft an diese Phase, wie wir gekämpft haben, dieses Interview mit allen EIC-Partnern zu koordinieren und den Zeitpunkt zu koordinieren, die Autorisierung durchzubekommen und das zu veröffentlichen. Da ist manchmal dann auch die, also vielleicht auch jetzt deine Anspruchshaltung an uns, nur begrenzt zu erfüllen, weil wir, wie gesagt, dann jetzt auch nicht, wir sind kein reines Football-Leaks-Unternehmen, sondern es gibt da halt auch schon viele andere Sachen, die man noch drumrum machen muss. Und wie gesagt, ich kann nicht zehn Leuten sagen, bitte mach das auch noch.
Dann ist ja noch etwas passiert, was ich vorhin schon mal angerissen habe, nämlich die Aufdeckung der Fäschungen von Klaas Relotios. Hat dieses Ereignis, was im Dezember letzten Jahres stattgefunden hat – und jetzt ist gerade ein Buch dazu erschienen von Juan Moreno, 1000 Zeilen Lügen – hat das deine Art und Weise verändert, wie du mit deiner eigenen Berichterstattung umgegangen bist?
Ja, im Endeffekt hat das ja schon vor Klaas schon längst stattgefunden, dass wir uns ins Besondere, wenn es um solche Geschichten wie es die Football Leaks aktuell sind, dass wir da nie alleine arbeiten, dass wir immer im Team arbeiten, dass wir uns gegenseitig versuchen, auch zu kontrollieren. Wir haben bei Football Leaks ja nicht nur ein reines Football Leaks Spiegel-Team, das damit arbeitet, sondern auf der anderen Seite auch 100 weitere – mittlerweile sind es ja fast 100 Journalisten, die im europäischen Ausland damit zu tun haben. 80 waren es für die Football Leaks 2, die jede einzelne unserer Enthüllungen noch mal viermal drehen und sich angucken, die Fragen an Rui Pinto übermittelt haben, die über das hinausging, was ich mit Pinto besprochen habe, die immer wieder auch so klare Sparring-Partner und vor allem Kontrollinstanzen für unsere eigene Arbeit sind und waren. Wir haben hier zumindest bei unserem Team die klare Haltung, dass wir große Investigativgeschichten nicht mehr oder nicht alleine machen, nicht nicht mehr, sondern nicht alleine machen. Das gilt aber für die ganzen letzten Jahre, weil wir uns einfach dann auch gegenseitig versuchen zu helfen und zu unterstützen, damit man nicht irgendwo einen blinden Fleck hat und damit hier nicht irgendwas durchrutscht. Das sind jetzt aber die völlig normalen Kontrollinstanzen, die wir haben. Das geht ja deutlich über das hinaus, was dort als Vorwurf über Klaas schwebt oder was dort als Vorwurf geäußert wurde.
Wobei es natürlich damals die Kontrollinstanzen auch gab und man im Nachhinein sagen muss, die haben in großen Teilen ihre Arbeit als kontrollierende Instanz nicht wirklich erfüllt.
Aber das ist was völlig anderes als die Art, die wir zum Arbeiten verwenden. Klaas war zu 99 Prozent alleine unterwegs. Viele seiner Geschichten hat er, seiner großen Reportage, hat er ganz alleine gemacht, oftmals auch ohne einen Fotografen, mit einem Dokumentar, der angebunden war, offenbar an das Ressort. Aber ich persönlich möchte für mich gar nicht so sehr in Anspruch nehmen, weiter über Klaas zu reden. Dafür ist jetzt der Huren der Experte, der darüber geschrieben hat. Das Haus hat einen großen, ich glaube auch in vielerlei Hinsicht, schonungslosen Report hingelegt und sich mit der Frage beschäftigt, wie uns das passieren konnte. Ich kann hier für mich, für unseren Investigativsektor sprechen und dort kann ich halt einfach nur sagen, dass wir deutlich intensiver auf die Beleglagen hinweisen, die Beleglagen auch drehen und versuchen, da auch selbstkritisch mit umzugehen, wenn uns etwas misslinkt. Das war ja in den letzten Tagen auch nachzulesen. Ich bin von einer eigenen Geschichte eingeholt worden aus dem Jahr 2014, bei der wir damals in der Tat ein zu großes Risiko mit dieser Geschichte gegangen sind. Ich bin immer noch überzeugt davon, dass diese Geschichte stimmt, aber wir haben eine Geschichte veröffentlicht, bei der wir einen Teil zumindest nicht mehr schriftlich belegen können.
Also es geht um verschobene WM-Gruppenspiele von Kamerun und im Nachhinein hat derjenige, mit dem du darüber gesprochen hast, Wilson Rai Perumal, ein Matchfixer, hat dann im Nachhinein gesagt, das was er dir gesagt hätte, wäre erst nach dem Spiel passiert, was du aber im Artikel so beschrieben hattest, dass er das angekündigt hätte. Es findet jetzt ein Eignis statt, was dann auch eintraf.
Ich finde das halt Wahnsinn, dass wir mittlerweile ja dann auch alles irgendwie vermengen mit Relotius und ich habe mich dann auf einmal jetzt auch in…
Naja, dieser Artikel wurde auch von der Relotius-Kommission überprüft. Deswegen gibt es da schon eine Verbindung.
Aber die Relotius-Kommission prüft ja hier zig Artikel von unterschiedlichen Personen. Die Relotius-Kommission, das ist vielleicht eine Namensfrage, dass man die Relotius-Kommission als Relotius-Kommission nennt. Man könnte sie auch Spiegel-Kommission oder sonst was nennen. Die Personen sind ja nicht eingeschossen auf Relotius. Sie haben nur mit Relotius begonnen, aber es geht ja hier. Wir diskutieren unsere eigenen Standards. Wir diskutieren darüber tagtäglich auch mit dieser Kommission, wie wir Dinge besser machen können bzw. wie wir mit Dingen besser umgehen können, wo wir vielleicht auch unseren eigenen Sinne schärfen können. Bei dem Artikel, über den wir gerade sprechen aus dem Jahr 2014, ist es ja so, dass ich eine eidesstattliche Versicherung eines Kollegen habe, der meine Darstellung damals gesehen hat. Ich habe einen Wettüberwacher, mit dem ich kurz nach dem Spiel gesprochen habe und ihm erzählt habe, wie meine Informationslage rund um Pedro mal ausgesehen hat bzw. rund um diesen Chat. Das hat oftmals gereicht. Man hatte zwei unabhängig voneinander agierende Personen, die sich zumindest darauf rekurrieren konnten. Bei denen haben wir dann gesagt, dass es eine halbwegs valide Beleglage ist, mit der wir uns in einem Risikobereich befinden. Aber wir wollen hier die Wahrheit schreiben. Wir wollen hier das schreiben, was stattgefunden hat. Also gehen wir auch an der Stelle ins Risiko. Aus heutiger Sicht – und das ist ja der entscheidende Punkt in der Glaubhaftmachung von Artikeln, in der wir uns jetzt aktuell finden, in einer Zeit, die das auch deutlich stärker einfordert – ist dieser Artikel in der Tat schwierig zu begründen. Ich könnte ihn nur begründen, wenn ich den Chat in der Form hochhalten könnte. Das kann ich aber nicht, im Übrigen, weil das auch zigmal falsch geschrieben wurde. Ich konnte es auch schon 2014 nicht. Das ist vielleicht der größte Unterschied zu all diesen Klaas-Vorwürfen und Relozius-Vorwürfen. Ich habe alle Instanzen in diesem Haus meine Beleglage vorgelegt und habe gesagt, das ist noch das, was ich habe. Das ist das, was für die Beleglage spricht.
Bevor der Artikel veröffentlicht wurde, meintest du?
Bevor der Artikel veröffentlicht wurde. Ich war damals in Brasilien.
Das ist ja für Außenstehende fast noch das Erschreckendere, dass dann dennoch dieser Artikel online ging, oder im Heft gedruckt wurde, Entschuldigung, auf dessen Grundlage ja dann auch die FIFA-Ermittlungen eingeleitet hat. Und das ist ja ein schwerer Vorwurf, dass ein WM-Spiel verschoben wird von einer Mannschaft, weil da mehrere Spieler, sogenannte, Zitat, faule Äpfel wären. Das war der Titel dieser Geschichte. Das ist ja fast nur frappierender, dass man das damals schon wusste, dass die Beleglage aus eurer Sicht schwierig ist und trotzdem dieser Artikel erst veröffentlicht wurde. Und dann im Nachhinein, auch obwohl er sehr früh dann schon in Kritik geraten ist, hat es jetzt fünf Jahre gedauert, bis der Spiegel sich dazu nochmal geäußert hat und das gerade gerückt hat. Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt schwerwiegender, als wenn dir die Belege danach irgendwie abhandengekommen wären.
Das sind aber Fragen, die sind größer als sie jetzt hier mit mir zu diskutieren. Das sind ja auch Hausfragen, um die es dabei geht, die zu stellen sind. Du hast gerade die Faule Äpfel angesprochen. Im Übrigen, das ist ja ein Zitat, das ich belegen kann. Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich das Gespräch mit Perumal erträumt habe, sondern es geht um die ersten eineinhalb Sätze, in dem Artikel gestritte ich bin. Bei denen ich sage, sie haben so stattgefunden, mein Zeuge, der das eidesstattlich für sich hat, sagt ebenfalls, die haben so stattgefunden. Und es gibt einen Wettüberwacher, der sagt, der Buschmann hat mir sehr früh davon erzählt, ich weiß es auch. Das ist die Beleglage auf der einen Seite. Wir haben aber auf der anderen Seite das Dementi von Perumal. Und wir haben eben nicht diesen vorderen physischen Teil des Chats. Wenn man sich dann aber anguckt, dass du gerade gesagt hast, der schwerwiegende Vorwurf ein Spiel sein manipuliert. Das ist ja der Vorwurf, den Perumal erhoben hat, den wir auch im Nachhinein noch belegen können. Er hat ja gesagt, dass alle drei Spiele von Cameroon manipuliert seien.
Er hat ja gesagt, es ist dort im Nachhinein gesagt.
Definitiv. Er hat es ja gesagt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich den Vorwurf alleine geäußert hätte, dass diese Spiele manipuliert waren. Trotzdem, um das nochmal abzukürzen, das Risiko bei der Geschichte war zu hoch. Wir sind dieses Risiko zu hoch eingegangen. Wir hätten im Prinzip genau, wie du es jetzt gerade sagst, damit arbeiten sollen, dass wir darstellen, dass Perumal behauptet, diese Spiele seien manipuliert. Dass er behauptet, dass die Spieler von Cameroon dort involviert waren. Ich glaube, sieben schwarze Schafe hat er genannt oder sieben faule Äpfel. Ich habe es nicht mehr genannt. Aber dass er das behauptet hat, das hätte vollkommen gereicht. Es hätte den Einstieg nicht gebraucht. Es war ja in der Logik, dann ging diese Geschichte ja weiter, dass Perumal drei Monate nach der Geschichte Unterlassung gegen uns gefordert hat. Kurz darauf hat Perumal sein gesamtes Facebook-Profil gelöscht. Er ist nie wieder mit seinen Anwälten auf uns zugekommen. Wir haben nie wieder etwas von dieser Geschichte gehört.
Er hatte aber natürlich auch andere Sorgen. Er war ja selbst in Finnland zu der Zeit, mit dem du mit ihm geschrieben hast. Korrigiere mich, wenn ich da gerade was durcheinander werfe. Er hatte ja durchaus seine eigenen juristischen Dinge gerade zu tun. Und was man aus anderen Quellen lesen kann, wo ich mich jetzt aber nur auf eine Quelle stütze, da gibt es einen sehr langen Blog-Eintrag, hatte er auch finanzielle Probleme zu der Zeit und musste sich über sehr spitze Voraussagen vielleicht auch wieder ein bisschen Geld verdienen. Also es könnte auch daran gelegen haben, will ich damit einfach nur sagen.
Natürlich kann es daran gelegen haben. Im Übrigen, um das nochmal gerade zu rücken, man braucht keine finanziellen Ressourcen für eine Unterlassungserklärung. Eine ein-zweilige Verfügung im ein-zweiligen Verfügungsverfahren zu erwirken, dafür bedarf es einer eidesstattlichen Versicherung, die man abgibt und sagt, dass dieser Chat so gelaufen ist, wie man ihn auch darstellt. Und dann läuft ein Anwalt los und holt das Ding ein. Es würde dann erst finanzielle Ressourcen nach sich ziehen, wenn es in einer Art Hauptsache-Verfahren oder so etwas gehen würde. Perumal hat schon den ersten Punkt nicht gemacht, obwohl er mit einer renommierten deutschen Kanzlei damals auf uns zugekommen ist. Es gibt bei dieser Geschichte ja zahlreiche Punkte, bei denen man von einem strittigen Ablauf sprechen kann. Wir haben uns jetzt dazu entschieden, einfach weil wir gesagt haben, dass wir diesen physischen Bereich des Schätzens nicht haben. Dass wir gesagt haben, wir nehmen die Geschichte raus, was ich für richtig halte. Was aber nicht bedeutet, dass wir uns nicht diese Geschichte nochmal angucken und auch nochmal zu dieser Geschichte recherchieren werden.
Du hättest, nachdem was berichtet wird, unter anderem bei Übermedien, bei der Süddeutschen Zeitung, Leiter der Investigativabteilung des Spiegel werden sollen. Da soll es interne Widerstände gegeben haben. Und das Ende der Geschichte ist jetzt auch, du wirst nicht Leiter dieser Abteilung. Hängt das nur mit diesem einen Artikel aus dem Jahr 2014 zusammen?
Also was mein Chefredakteur in der Öffentlichkeit gesagt hat, was ich bestätigen kann, ist, dass ich auf die Beförderung verzichtet habe, dass ich sie unter diesen Umständen auch nicht wahrnehmen möchte. Mir ist nicht bekannt, dass irgendjemand hier Widerstände gegen mich geäußert hätte, die in irgendeiner Form mit meiner Arbeitsweise zu tun gehabt hätten. Dass dieser Artikel hier auch im Haus strittig war und hier besprochen wurde. Das hat mehrere Gründe, dass im Zuge einer solchen Beförderungsfrage ein 5 Jahre alter Artikel dann nochmal herangezogen wird. Das hat eine Koinzidenz, über die man, wie auch immer, geartet nachdenken kann. Aber es ist für mich auch, um ehrlich zu sein, unerheblich, weil ich an der Stelle dann auch für mich sage, dass das Reporterleben ein sehr tolles Leben ist. Ich freue mich weiterhin auf dieses Reporterleben und glaube, dass ich mit dem Pinto-Prozess mehr als genug zu tun haben werde. Dementsprechend ist dieser Weg, den wir hier eingeschlagen sind, der richtige.
Und verzeih mir die eine misstrauische Nachfrage dann noch. Es bezieht sich jetzt aber nur auf den Faule-App für Artikel aus dem Jahr 2014. Es gab keine anderen Artikel, in denen Zitatlagen, Belege für vorgebrachte Fakten, für Behauptungen gefehlt hätten, an denen du beteiligt gewesen wärst.
Ich habe mich mit der Kommission zu einem weiteren Artikel, mit dem ich mit Ihnen darüber geredet habe. Das konnte ich, glaube ich, sehr gut erklären. Es ist ja jetzt einfach so, dass diese Nachfragen im Zuge der Untersuchung auch von außen gekommen sind. Ich habe versucht, das so gut wie möglich darzustellen.
Kannst du sagen, welcher Artikel das ist?
Nein, es ist unerheblich. Ich habe mir meine Beleglage dargestellt und dieser Artikel ist in keiner Art und Weise weiter behandelt worden. Ja, das ist, glaube ich, der Punkt.
Also keine weiteren Artikel, bei denen noch irgendwann aufploppen konnte. Da hat jetzt ein Beleg gefehlt oder es wurde ein Zitat verwendet, was nicht im Nachhinein noch mal nachrecherchiert werden kann von der Dokumentation.
Was heißt denn, die Frage versteht, inwiefern soll ein Zitat nachrecherchiert werden, das vielleicht, keine Ahnung, vor zehn Jahren oder sonst was abgegeben wurde? Also ich finde, die Perumal-Geschichte, da gibt es einen validen Punkt. Es gibt eine schriftliche Auseinandersetzung, bei der jemand sagt, ich habe hier einen Beleg, bei dem ich nachweisen kann, dass die schriftliche Auseinandersetzung später stattgefunden hat, als der Redakteur es behauptet. Und der Redakteur sagt, ich ziehe hier mehrere physische Quellen heran, die erklären sollen, dass meine Darstellung stimmt. An der Stelle ist es ein strittiger Punkt, bei dem ich selbst sage, das Schriftliche überwiegt. Also das heißt, solange ich diesen Chat nicht habe, was ja auch noch nicht ausgeschlossen ist, dass wir ihn irgendwann mal bekommen, aber solange ich diesen Chat nicht habe, finde ich es besser, diese Geschichte dann auch aus dem Netz zu nehmen oder diese Geschichte nicht weiterhin als strittige Geschichte auch über dem Haus schweben zu haben. Aber ich meine, wir dürfen jetzt, finde ich, auch diesen Berufsstand, den wir haben, nicht sämtlich überhöhen. Wir haben alle ganz oft mit Geschichten zu tun, bei denen man zwei Quellen, drei Quellen hat, die einem etwas sagen, mit denen man zu tun hat, den man dann in dem Moment, in dem man die Recherche macht, ja auch vertrauen muss, weil man dann an dem Punkt eine Übereinstimmung hat oder weil man an dem Punkt eine valide Information hat, die zu dem jeweiligen Zeitpunkt Sinn ergibt. Ich habe meine Beleglagen, dem Spiegel in ausführlichster Deutlichkeit immer gezeigt, mit ihm besprochen, sei es jetzt mit meiner Ressortleiterin, mit der Rechtsabteilung, mit der Chefredaktion, mit Kollegen, an denen ich daran gearbeitet habe. Deswegen, ja, misstrauische Fragen bin ich in meinem Berufsstand gewöhnt, aber ich glaube, dass auch eine gewisse Form von Fairness irgendwie auch an einen selbst auch noch herangezogen werden darf.
Fair enough, wie man so schön sagt im Englischen. Wir sind jetzt schon zehn Minuten über der Zeit. Würdest du mir noch fünf Minuten geben, um über die Rezeption der Football Leaks und vielleicht einen möglichen Ausblick zu sprechen? Hast du die noch? Wie würdest du denn jetzt rückblickend die Rezeption in Deutschland beschreiben? Bist du zufrieden mit dem, was sich jetzt auch verändert hat durch die Football Leaks?
Schwierig. Daran messe ich mich nicht. Ich messe meine Recherchen nicht daran, ob sie am Ende für eine ausreichende Rezeption oder für eine ausreichende Veränderung in der Gesellschaft gesorgt haben. Das können wir gar nicht. Ich habe es gerade versucht, anklingeln zu lassen. Wir sollten den Berufsstand der Journalisten auch nicht dauerhaft überhöhen. Wir sollten ihn nicht auf die allerhöchsten Podeste stellen. Wir sind weder Politiker noch Richter noch Staatsanwälte. Wir stellen die Welt so dar, wie sie sich in dem jeweiligen Augenblick ergibt oder wie sie sich uns zeigt. Wenn am Ende die Gesellschaft etwas anderes daraus machen will, wenn die Gesellschaft weiterhin Lust hat, das Treiben des Fußballs in der Form zu begleiten, wenn Politiker weiterhin den Wert von Fußball höher einschätzen als möglicherweise die Kontrolle dieser Branche, dann ist das etwas... Womit ich lebe. Womit ich leben muss.
Es ist natürlich der Whistleblower wichtiger. Also weißt du, so komme ich zu der Frage, wenn Rui Pinto sagt, er ist ein bisschen enttäuscht.
Und deswegen wollte ich halt den nächsten Schritt machen. Ich habe vor ein paar Tagen das Buch von Edward Snowden zu Ende gelesen. Das ist jetzt auch nicht ein Jubelbuch über die Auswirkung des Whistleblowings rund um staatliche Überwachung. Das ist auch ein Buch, das sich sehr kritisch und selbstkritisch damit auseinandersetzt, das sich eigentlich relativ wenig verändert hat, sondern stattdessen eine Zunahme staatlicher Überwachung stattfindet. Insbesondere, weil wir uns alle mittlerweile dem Smartphone ausliefern, weil wir uns alle Alexa oder sonst was in unsere Häuser stellen, weil wir uns auf eine Art und Weise vernetzen und digitalisieren, die jeden unserer Schritte transparent machen und darstellen. Wenn Rui Pinto sagt, dass ihm das alles nicht ausreicht, habe ich das auch im letzten Jahr schon verstanden. Er hat mir das in aller Deutlichkeit gesagt, dass er glaubt, dass jetzt die nächste Stufe seines Projekts stattfinden muss. Und das ist die Stufe des Weggehens von der rein öffentlichen Wahrnehmung hin zu einer Unterstützung staatlicher Organe. Deswegen hat er ja über so einen langen Zeitraum auch versucht, eine Anbindung an Behörden und an Autoritäten zu finden, um dort zu unterstützen. Das vergisst man ja immer in dieser ganzen Gemengelage. Aber Pinto ist im Prinzip wenige Tage verhaftet worden, bevor er in einer Art Zeugenschutzprogramm nach Frankreich sollte. Das war alles zu dem Zeitpunkt schon relativ festgezuhrt. Er hatte die klare Aussicht, dass er in Frankreich als Whistleblower die französischen Behörden hätte unterstützen sollen. Wenige Tage vorher ist er von den ungarischen Behörden auf Druck der portugiesischen Staatsanwaltschaft oder Generalstaatsanwaltschaft verhaftet worden. Dementsprechend für ihn war dieses Projekt nicht an der Stelle zu Ende, dass wir ein Football Leaks 2 veröffentlicht haben, sondern eigentlich hätte es dort anfangen sollen. Er hätte dort die Möglichkeit ergreifen sollen, Stadtliebebehörden zu unterstützen.
Es muss ja jetzt auch noch nicht das Ende des Projekts sein. Trotzdem möchte ich diese eine schleifend bindende Frage dann noch zum Abschluss stellen. Wenn wir jetzt mal kurz zurückblicken auf den Beginn von Football Leaks bis jetzt, würdest du im Nachhinein nochmal alles, was du in deiner Rolle als Journalist und Berichterstatter gemacht hast, genauso machen?
Ich wäre ja verrückt, wenn ich das jetzt auch nur ansatzweise mit einem Ja bezeichnen würde. Ich glaube, mit jeder Woche, die wir hatten, haben wir hier in unserer Reflektionsgruppe darüber gesprochen, was wir hätten verändern können. Und das fängt an mit der Art, wie wir mit Daten arbeiten. Das fängt an mit der Klassifikation von Daten. Das fängt an mit den Systemen, die wir dafür wählen. Aber das geht natürlich auch dann zu den großen Themen, wie – keine Ahnung – dem Umgang mit dem Whistleblower, möglicherweise dann auch der Fragestellung, ob wir dieses Projekt, ob es in der Tat nicht früher hätte zu Ende sein sollen, sein können. Das sind aber Fragen, die kann ich gar nicht beantworten, sondern die umtreiben mich. Die umtreiben mich, weil ich mir dann ja auch die Frage stelle, was eigentlich mit Pinto gewesen wäre, wenn wir im Januar 2018 gesagt hätten, das war es jetzt, wie er sein Leben gestaltet hätte. Aber das sind Fragen, die kriege ich gar nicht verändert. Da kann ich dann für mich vielleicht bestimmte Punkte rausnehmen oder kann für mich im Umgang mit Informanten dann auch in den letzten dreieinhalb Jahren so viel gelernt wie in meiner ganzen beruflichen Zeit vorher nicht. Dieses Projekt war so intensiv oder ist intensiv. Dieses Projekt hat uns alle sowohl körperlich als auch an intellektuelle Grenzen gebracht, weil wir immer wieder im Minutentakt mit Entscheidungen konfrontiert waren, die wir vorher vielleicht so noch nie getroffen haben. All das in der Gemengelage – ich habe das nochmal während des Schreibens des Buches gemerkt, wie mich das aufgewühlt hat an manchen Punkten, wenn ich mir überlegt habe, wie müde, wie kaputt, wie vielleicht auch einfach durch wir an manchen Stellen waren und trotzdem dann eben mit der nächsten Enthüllung konfrontiert waren, mit der nächsten Entwicklung konfrontiert waren. Das ist ja kein Projekt gewesen, das wie bei anderen Geschichten mit einer Geschichte abgeschlossen war. Dann waren drei Wochen Pause und dann hat man die nächste Geschichte gemacht, sondern das ging hier dreieinhalb Jahre Schlag auf Schlag. Und wir alle diskutieren jetzt auch darüber, wie wir bestimmte Dinge auch in Zukunft in unseren Prozessen dann nochmal anpassen, verändern würden. Also insofern dafür war es sehr gut und dafür ist es immer noch sehr gut, dass wir unsere eigenen Arbeitsweisen nochmal ganz erheblich dadurch schärfen konnten und können.
Apropos Schlag auf Schlag, Apropos Mühde, ich habe dir jetzt 17 nicht vereinbarte Minuten geklaut. Ich möchte an der Stelle danken, dass du dich jetzt schon zum vierten Mal sehr ausführlich im Rasenfunk meinen Fragen gestellt hast. Wir hatten auch schon Q&As, wo die Hörerinnen und Hörer die Fragen gestellt haben. Danke, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, trotz der vielen Anfragen, die es bestimmt gibt und eben der Dinge, die du jetzt zu tun hast. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich kann euch nur empfehlen, widmet euch auch den anderen Tribünengesprächen. Auch das Tribünengespräch zum FIFA-Prozess hängt so irgendwie mit der Konstellation des Sujets. Dann doch auch mit den Football Leaks zusammen, kann ich euch sehr ans Herz legen. Ansonsten unterstützt den Rasenfunk, wenn ihr möchtet. Hinterlasst uns Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk in der Schlusskonferenz, dem Kurzpass oder hier im Tribünengespräch. Macht's gut, ciao!
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.